foreign
development week by simply learn so far
we have discussed the fundamental
building blocks of software development
the data structures and algorithms
worried that you missed out on those no
problem we'll have them Linked In the
cards and description box below as
announced we will be getting started
with the whole program and language
today
and also we will tap into object
oriented programming Concepts and
details so far we have learned the
fundamentals using both structural
programming lens and objective
programming launch and clearly you must
have off programming using object-based
approaches object oriented programming
makes the software development process
more streamlined and secure well how
exactly is that don't you order experts
will now take over and explain them to
you in a more detailed way along with
practical implementation for a better
learning experience now over to our
experts we will start by understanding
the introduction to C plus plus
programming then we will learn how to
download and install C plus plus in
Windows
after that we will how to
write first programming C plus plus
types and variables and fill statements
we will also look at the loops in C plus
plus function since it's called by
values topics like arrays strings
pointers memory management along with
Hands-On examples then we will cover
object oriented programming topics like
classes in C plus plus oops concept and
operator overloading and at last we will
cover some topics like vectors in C plus
plus STL and C plus plus enumerations
will also cover all these topics with
Hands-On examples so that it will be
easy for you to understand and
so without further Ado let's get get
started
start production to program C plus run
into dual stroke in the East the aim was
to make a dynamic language that is
efficient and has some additional
features to see
initially it was called C with classes
as it was an extension to C language but
later renamed as C plus plus
it is general purpose case sensitive
language and it is called pre-compiled
language because it converts the source
code directly to the machine
understandable code
it is an intermediate level language
because it contains both features of
high level low level language
supports of object oriented language
like Absolution intense
polymorphicycle supports procedural
programming and functional programming
as well welcome to this video where
we'll be telling you how you can install
C plus on vs code and Dev C plus
to download vs code let's go to Google
and search for visual studio code
or vs code
we'll click on this first link
this is the official web page for
downloading in the visual studio code
and and we will click on this download
for Windows Blue Button
for now
here it is getting download and Elkins
thanks
we are done with the download we can
click on this open folder
here it is
now we need to install this file so
we'll double click on this file
and this is a set of zart
we'll click on this I accept the
agreement
and we'll click on next
licensing agreement now we can select
our destination folds but make 293 for
free space on that particular now
we'll click on next
here we can again click on X there is no
need to change over here
and now
you can click on this create a desktop
icon button or anyone else as per your
choice
now we'll click on next
and now we'll click finally on install
it is getting installed it will take
some time
now we can click button launch Visual
Studio we have marked it it is already
marked so when we click on this finish
button it will launch the visual studio
code
so as we can see this is the visual
studio code
so as we have installed vs code now we
have to configure it so that the C plus
plus programs can run in this editor
so in order to do that we need to add
some extensions so we'll click on this
extension button
now here I'll write
code Runner extension
right code Runner
and this is extension and click on this
and hitting installed
here are some instructions we can click
on control plus all plus n or press F1
and then select type run code but we'll
deal with that later
now
we'll add another extension that is
C
slash C plus plus
here it is
we'll click on this install
here you can see it downloading video
Studio Windows debug it is getting
installed and installed as we have a
smooth one of C plus plus the first
beginners a program
in this program hello world is printed
it is very basic program and in the
first part of the program we are
including a header file hash include
iostream
header files are generally put features
into the program functions like C in
which is used to take the input from the
user and see out which is used to
display the output are defined in this
iPhone header file
here using namespace standard means we
are using all the things which are
within the standard Library
the second part program is mutation
special attention from where the
execution program starts inside the main
function we are
printing hello world which is used to
print it on the next line decade the
program that nothing will return and
program executed successfully
so let's try this hello world program on
our code editor that is vs code
so let's first of all name the file
hello.cpp
so first of all we'll include the header
files
hash include iostream
and then space standard will using
namespace
stdp
now we'll write the main function that
is int Main
now
use C out
and we'll write
hello world
after that we'll write return 0.
all right now let's try to run this
as we can see hello world is getting
printed over here
so this is how it is done
so now let's move to our next pick
that is types and variables
two types and variable
different types of data types full
variable
first is Boolean data type this keyword
is used when we have two values either
true or false and these values are used
when there are conditions for example if
the condition is satisfied then it's
true otherwise it will return false
next is character data type this
character data type is used when we are
dealing with alphabets and symbols and
it is used to hold a single character
within the
table
in data type
this data type is used for integer they
can be negative next is Port is used
that are
now variables variables are used with
these data types it is generally used to
store values and this is the syntax to
Define a variable
first we will mention the data type and
then the variable name of our choice for
example int is the data type and data is
the variable name
our next topic is strings we can Define
strings as a collection or group of
characters it is basically used to
in the Pro
program
and we can
perform many
new presentations on strings in
manipulate the syntax of student by
double quotes
assigned to the string
in C plus plus there are two ways to
create a string
first is C style strings in C style
strings collection of characters are
stored in the form of Errors they are
basically arrays of type character
the second way is using string objects
we can create string object to hold a
string
they are implemented in the standard
Library
which
include
in the program using
hashing
include
now let's move on to the next example
let's do three
so we'll do an example and we'll do some
push back and pull back operation on it
so first of all we'll include the header
file
hash include iostream
then using namespace standard
namespace standard okay now we'll start
with int Main
all right first of all for
people we will write string
data type name of the string SS is the
name of the string now the string
so
okay enter a string
now
get line
this is the syntax when you want to take
the input
over first string so get sin is input
and S is the how we take the and it's
saying that
you have entered
now here we will print the string s
foreign
[Music]
okay
now
we build them operations like as back
delete the end
to add y
so we'll write y inside the bracket
s dot pushback and inside the bracket
with single quotes we'll write y
now
will display a message saying
after
using
push
function
will return
the strike and
now
we'll use another function s dot pop
back
it will delete the element from the end
so we'll write C out
and we'll display the message
after using popback function
only and we'll print
string
okay now after that we'll write return
0.
and I think it's done only the spelling
is wrong over here
okay
yeah now let's try to run this
as you can see the message enter a
string so let's say I invented
by Barcelona
so you have entered Barcelona after you
kind of used what we want to add y at
the end of the string so after using
pushback Barcelona Y and pop back
function after that we have used and we
know that it will delete the element
from the end so
here we can see there is no y pop back
function have deleted the element
so this is our output
next is if else statements
if else are two conditional statements
that are generally used when we want to
run the code based on some conditions
we run a block of code which is inside
statement if the condition is true for
example
well number here is equal to and will
print the message you got it
otherwise it will run the else block and
display the message written inside that
block which is not this one so first of
all we'll create a new file we'll go to
file and click on this new file
now in order to save this one we can
click on control s or we can go over
here and click on this save as
now we can select the location
like
let's keep it up over here only
Let's test visual CPP which is used with
C plus plus
now I will click on this save button
now let's do a simple program to check
whether the program is running on this
code editor or not
so we'll include the header files
hash include IO stream
now we'll write namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
now inside internet main will display a
message
welcome to this video
turn zero
store to save this after making changes
or you can click on Ctrl s or you can go
to file
and click on this save
so once you have saved the program now
you can run it
we can click on this play button it will
run the code
as we can see in the output
welcome to this video we can see
here it is
so it means our program
um is
working
it is running fine now let's do another
example in which you will take inputs
from new file go to file new file
now we'll save as
and we'll write visual
2 dot CPP
all right in this program we'll take the
input from the user
so start with
header files hash include iostree
our spelling is wrong hash include
iostream after that using namespace
standard
now inside int me inputs
will display the message
enter the
first number
Now using C in
we'll take the input
we forgot to mention this declare this
N1 with variable so write it into N1
and and to
and it
Circle 0 right here when the input of N1
but we'll take the number I displaced
enter the second number
we'll write N2
now we'll
add both of these
and one plus
N2
and will display the result
we'll write end line
so that it looks good
all right now we need to save it we'll
click on this now it is saved now we can
run this program
I will click on this run code
now in order to write the first number
over here that is in order to write in
the terminal we have to configure the
visual studio code and to do that
we'll go to file
and we'll now go to preference and in
the settings we'll click on the settings
and here we will type run in terminal
all right now we can scroll down
here we can see code review it is
already marked but you have to mark this
if you want to write in terminal or
enter the inputs in the terminal
all right once you have marked this you
can
close it and then you can control s that
is save and then you can close the vs
studio and then open it again
one button
oh
let's try to run this
so you will be able inputs
like let's say 4
the first number is 4
now the second number let's say
9.
on addition it becomes 13 which is the
right answer
so these were some configurations that
you need to do if you want to run a
program of C plus plus in Visual Studio
code
so as we have understood how to download
and configure Visual Studio code for C
plus plus programs so let's move on to
learn how we can download Dev C plus
plus and C plus plus programs in that
so let's go to Google
enter Dev C plus plus
this is the first
we'll click on that now this is the
green button saying download will click
on that to download Dev C plus
as you can see it is getting downloaded
your download will start shortly
so now we'll click on download now
it is getting downloaded
it will take a while the size of this
file is 48.1 MB
so as you can see the downloading is
almost done
so the down now we'll click on open
folder
here it is Dev C plus plus setup now
we'll click on this setup
please click on yes
the setup is loading
so now here we will select the preferred
language it is English
click on OK OK
now
we'll click on this is the like
no
neat thing that is 6.8 M mixed
now if you want to change the
destination folder you can but I don't
want to change it so I'll click on
install
now it is getting installed it will take
a while
it's done and
now I will click on finish and it is
marked over when we click the dev C plus
plus
so here we have to select the language
it is English so we'll click on next
here again we'll click on next and now
we'll click on OK
so this is our code editor that is Dev C
plus plus
so let's write a code
first of all let's create a file
we'll go to file and go to new
please
file
all right now we need one and on file
then we'll go to save as
and now we'll select the destination
and name it as
dev.cpp
all right now let's start
with the header file
hash include I have stream
we'll do a simple program over here
using
namespace
3D because net weather is running in
namespace STD
now we'll write into Main
inside into main will display a message
welcome
to
Dev
C plus plus
all right after that we'll write return
0.
now let's try to run this
and in order to run this program we will
go to execute
and now we'll click on compile and
this is the welcome to Dev C plus plus
as we can see this is the output now
press any key to continue it will close
this window
so our output is correct welcome to Dev
C plus plus so this is how you can run a
program in Dev C plus plus
and
our program was also working fine in the
visual studio code
moving on to while loops
in order to perform a particular task or
operation many number of times we need
loops these are used when we want to
execute a block of statement repeatedly
rather than just
writing those statements again again and
again
for example imagine you wanted your name
now to do that there is Method one is
writing your name 50 times by doing the
hard code
and Method two is writing your name once
with a loop condition and your name will
be automatically displayed 50 times
now it is pretty obvious that you would
prefer the second approach because you
don't have to put effort in writing your
name 50 times plus it is easy to write
code in few lines
so method 2 is the functionality of loop
it reduces time in writing the code plus
eating increase
simplicity
now let's understand what is
Loops in computer is a series of tasks
that are used to run so repeatedly until
a specific condition is met
Loops tells the computer when to start
the condition and when to stop it
now this is a basic flow of a loop after
the initialization the condition is
checked if it's true then the blog of
statement will get executed as long as
the condition is true and if the
condition is false the loop will
terminate
depending on the program different types
of Loops are used in different times
so let's first see different types of
loops
first is for for Loop
then while loop there is while loop
after that there is four type plus plus
discuss these loops
first is for Loop it is a repetition
control structure that is used to
iterate a piece of code based on the
condition is true or false if the
condition is true the statement inside
the loop body is executed and once if it
returns Falls the execution of statement
will get turned and after every
execution of for Loop the incremental
decrement parts will update the loop
counter
now let's move on to the while loop
in this Loop the condition is evaluated
first if it's true then the set of
instruction inside the Loop body will
execute
this will happen repeated the condition
becomes false the loop will end
now the main difference is we use four
Loops when we know the number of times
the body of the loop needs to run
whereas we use while Loops when we don't
know the accurate number of times the
body of loop needs to run
now moving to the next Loop that is do
by Loop
this Loop is quite similar to the while
loop in this the loop will execute the
set of instructions once before checking
if the condition is true after that it
will repeat the loop as long as the
condition true
that means
in do while
blue body will execute a respect coming
to the nested Loop
when one Loop is defined inside the body
of another loop then it is known as
nested Loop in C plus plus there are at
least 256 levels of nesting and the flow
of execution for nested Lopez First it
includes initialization of variable
followed by condition 1 if it gets
satisfied then it will search for the
second condition if that also gets
satisfied then it will get increment and
when the condition gets satisfied it
will search for the new set of
statements and follows the same flow of
execution
now
coming to the control
flow statements
the controlled from the loop by
terminating it basically break
statements are used when we are not sure
about the number of iterations or we
want the loop to end on some condition
now we will discuss about continue
statement
continuous also a loop control statement
it is used to skip the current iteration
of the loop and control of program goes
to the next iteration in other words if
continue is mentioned inside the loop it
skips the current statement and transfer
the control to execute the next
situation
the loop
now
as we have discussed these stuff let's
do some examples that is vs code now in
the file as
Loops dot CPP
okay
oops1.cpp
now here we will do a program in which
we have to print the digits from 0 to 10
using for loops it will be a basic
program just to understand it
write the header file
hash upload I'll stream
USP standard
now here is the ink name
now we'll write the for loop with a for
keyword
inside the for Loop
will initialize I with 0
now we'll put a condition I less than
equal to 10
which means
the loop will keep on executing until I
is less than 10.
now
we'll put
and
I plus plus
side the loop to do is to print I
so that all the digits get printed
so now let me tell you here what we are
doing is
we are just making the loop to run to
10. as we can see that I have made i 0
to I less than equal to 10 that means
Loop will move from i 0 to 10.
now let's try to run it
you can see
all little one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten
here is our answer and
let me tell you one thing more to put
return zero
after the loop it's a good practice
now I'll again run it
the output will be the same but it's a
good practice to write return 0 in the
end
zero one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
so instead of right
in the heart
cool
we can just
use the for Loop in this case
it's in base for Loop you can try some
more
let's do one to understand it better
we'll be doing a basic example of while
loop in which all we have to do is to
print happy New Year 11 times
let's start first of all let's name this
file
loops2.cpp
now let's start with the header file
that is Hash include iostream
we'll write using namespace standard
is the main
now first of all we'll declare n equals
0 we'll take a variable n and initialize
it with zero
now we'll put the while condition
keyword writing while
n
not equal to 11.
here what it means is
the loop will keep on executing until n
becomes equal to 11.
now here all we have to do is
print happy New Year so
that it will get printed
along with the Loop 11 times
handle
foreign
we have written n plus plus so that the
loop will keep on incrementing every
single time
after that now we'll write return 0
outside the loop
now we'll try to run this
so here
's a route
11 times so done
basic example of while loop candid one
must samples on it now while loop also
let's make a new file
first of all let's name that file
loops3.cpp
I think the name is already taken
then we'll write loops 4.
okay
so you will write the head file
we'll write
hash included
now in this program all we have to do is
we have to print the sum of all the
digits from 0 to 9.
so let's start
we'll write incline
so now let's first of all declare
accounting variable sum and initialize
it with 0.
now we will initialize another variable
I
with zero
now the syntax will do while loop is do
and now we will add the body
we'll write sum equals sum plus I
here what we are doing is we are simply
adding some variable and I variable and
storing it to some variable itself
we are doing this because we want to
find the sum that is why we have to
store it in a single variable
now we will need to increment I or else
Loop is going to run forever
now we will write by
file less
then 10 we have written as denta I want
to find the sum from Z and make sure
colon in the end in case of 2 while loop
now we will print
some
in this while loop
we'll write sum is
some variable
now this Loop will keep on executing
till I is less than 10.
now in the do while loop sum is
calculated by repeated addition and
increment in each repetition it is
checked whether the number I is
equal to
the inputted
number
if
smaller than
the loop
continues
but exits the loop
if it isn't
after the controls from the loop sum is
printed
now to run this code
is 45
Loops 5 dot CPP
now we'll start with the header files
Now using namespace standard
now
going just
program
all we have to do
is to
print
star
of half pyramid form using
let's try
Main
size two variables that is I
now let's say we want to make a half
frame rate of 10 rows then it means we
need to run a loop which runs for 10
times
so let's write
or
initialize it to zero
I less than
10.
I plus plus
so here we have written eyelab
us then
instead of this we'll write
I'll equal to 10 we want this type
printed also
slash in order to insert a new line
now we'll write another for Loop
which will decide number of stars in a
particular row
so we'll write J equal to 1 because this
for Loop is for the column section
then J less than equal to I
which is a row
then J plus plus
now
we will print
star
nothing instead of 1 from 1 to 10.
so now let's discuss its working
initially we have I equals to 1 that is
the outer loop value
now for this value a complete run of jth
loop is happening that is J equal to 1
validated by J less than equal to I
now this condition is used because the
pattern which we are going to build is
having increment of Star as the number
of rows increments
so for
I
equals to 1
to 1 is execute
then J plus plan which increments the
value of the to 2 now J equals to
execute S21 is false only one start
again equal to we'll check every value
of J which can be executed that is 1 and
2. since only two values can be true
therefore two stars are printed
similarly we check for I equal to 3 4 5
and so on till 9. as we have the
condition I is less than 10.
so now
perfect
this
and check whether the thing or not
here it is half pyramid bars with the
help nested Loop so this is our
make some types of using a product to
understand the cons let's move to our
control flow statements
and let's do some examples of them
okay now
make a new file
let's name this file as
Ctrl 1.
dot CPP
now we'll write the header file and the
name
paste tender
as we have done previously
let's do it
include
I
namespace STD
now here we will write a program in
which we have to print the numbers from
100 to 200 like 110 hundred and twenty
hundred and thirty with a gap of 10. but
after 150 we will terminate the ongoing
Loop
now how can it be done with the help of
break statement so let's start
first of all we'll write intimate
now we'll take a variable num
and initialize it with
now we will write a while
and we'll run equal to 200 because we
want the loop to run from
less than equal to
now we'll simply display those numbers
foreign
statement inside
let's write
if num equals equals 150
then we have to break
the loop
write the break statement
now after that we'll implement this
by 10.
we're incrementing this by 10 because we
want the numbers to be printed like 100
hundred and ten hundred and twenty like
this that is why we are incrementing it
with 10 and not with one
now we'll out of the loop
just to be
informed that we
finally out of the loop
returns it now we'll try
to see yesterday 200 that out this means
the coin
a couple of a break statement now after
this we'll do another example of
continue so let's start
let's make a new file
and name it
ctrl2.cpv
now we'll write the header files
[Music]
names
to standard
now print the numbers excluding 96 now
with the help of continue so let's start
first of all we'll write into Main
now we'll declare a variable
num and initialize it with 100.
now we'll write a while condition
while loop in which we write the
condition num greater than equal to 90
because we want the loop to run till it
is equal to 90 that is why we have wrote
greater than equal to 90. basically we
want the loop to run from 100
till it comes equal to 90.
now inside the loop we'll inverse
so we'll write if
num equals 96 now
quilts equals 96.
now we'll use a decrement operator
because our starting point is 100 our
ending point is 90. that is why we have
to use the decrement operator
now continues
statement
after that
right
and we'll write the variable
now we'll write num minus minus
here we are writing minus minus because
we want it to get decrement after
printing also that is why we have
written num minus minus after printing
num
now let's try to run this also hope it
works
okay I think there are some
foreign
here it is
as we can see
199.98 97
but 96 is missing
so this is all we have to do in this
program
and this is the basic example of
continue statement
in order to understand these examples
better you must try more examples on
each of these
blue
control flow
statements
so that it will be easier for you all
you got is a function functions are
blocks of code that's your task into
smart and make the stand and reusable
and by reusable it means we can Define
the code once and we can use it many
times
we can also pass data into the functions
in the form of parameters
and this is the syntax
first is return type of the function
then we will write function name then
inside the bracket these are the
parameters
now let's discuss why we use functions
functions make the program less
complicated
because once
function is
defined in the program then it can be
used over and over again to Deluxe and
please send it to user due to this we
can easily debug and maintain the code
now coming to the types of functions
there are two types of functions in C
plus plus that is built-in functions and
user defined function
now let's discuss these functions
first is built-in function
these are also known as predefined
functions or Library functions we don't
need to Define these functions because
these are already present in C plus
libraries and the implementation of
these functions are also available in
library file
and to use these functions we don't have
to write them separately we simply call
them
now
coming to the
find functions
C plus plus allows the programmers
requirement this allows a way to wrap a
set of statements to perform a specific
task and that group of statement is
given so that it can be invoked later
from any part of the program
following is the example of user defined
function here Club is a user defined
function with the return type void and
it is being called from the main
function now let's learn about function
declaration
function declaration basically acts as
an identification for the function
it informs the compiler about the
existence of function
functions name
the number
of parameters in the function turn type
1 this is the Syntax for a function that
first we will write the return type then
we will write the name of the function
after that inside the bracket we will
write the number of parameters
for example in this chess function int
is the return type chess is the name of
the function
and inside the brackets these are the
number of parameters
although we can write the names of
parameters but names of parameters are
not important in the function
declaration only their type is required
now let's learn about function calling
in order to use a function we'll have to
invoke or call a function when a program
calls a function the control of the
program is to transfer to the cold
function when the code completes task
then the control is in program
so the functions are called by writing
the name of function and after that
writing the required parameters inside
the brackets
and this is the syntax
first we will write the function name
and after that we will write the
arguments which we want to pass
for example sum is the function name and
a and b are the arguments
moving on to another video on call by
value and call by reference in C plus
plus call by value is a method in which
copies of variables are passed to the
functions and as the cop is a variables
or
are being passed
so that is why the changes that the
function affect the argument and in
passing the here well 1 and well 2 are
the actual parameters these are those
which are passed to the functions
and inside the brackets of call function
we can see N1 and N2
these are formal parameters
foreign parameters are those which are
received by the function
so here we can say values of actual
parameters that is well 1 and well 2
will be copied to the formal parameters
that is N1 and N2
now let's have a look at an example in
which we are swapping two numbers
as we can see inside int main we have
assigned 120 to X and 152i
after that we have called a
function named swept inside the kids
passing the values of NY
and these values are getting received by
called function
and inside that function there is a
logic to swap the code with the help of
temporary variable temp
and these values of X and Y are then
displayed inside int Main
but its output is same
access till 120 and Y is still 150 there
is no change after swapping it also
so this shows that actual value of the
variable is not getting modified
this shows that changes done to the
parameters inside the function does not
affect the arguments
now learn about call by reference and
third instead of passing the arguments
the address of the argument is passed to
the formal arguments of the function
and the address is used to access the
actual argument referring to the same
location so any changes that are made
gets reflected to the actual parameter
this is the syntax of call by reference
in which we have assigned 200 to the
variable num and then the address of
this variable is passed to the function
and 20 is assigned to it
now on displaying the output the value
would be 20 and not 200 because the
value is assigned to the memory location
that changes
getting
selected
now but look at envelope swap the same
example is that but instead of passing
the copies of variable using the address
of the variable
and inside the function values are
getting swapped with the help of temp
variable and then it is getting
displayed in the main function
in this case we can see in the output
the values of variables are actually
swapped m is now 300 and N is now 250.
now let's do some examples of call by
value and call by reference in our code
editor that is vs code
now we will do an example of call by
value in which we will try to change the
rib with the help of a function
foreign
let's make
one dot CPP
now we will include the header files
hash include
i o stream
now we will add namespace standard
now first of all we'll write int Main
and we will declare a variable cell
and assign
fine a value
000 let's do this
now we will call a
let's name that function as salary
underscore change
and now inside the brackets we'll write
cell
as we know that in call by value we pass
the copies of the variable
so
now we'll display
that variable
we'll write
value
okay
and now we will write the variable name
cell
and handle
now
return zero
now let's make the function salary
change
we'll write
void
salary underscore
change
void
now here we will write hint the data
type and the variable
s that is the formal parameter so cell
here is the actual parameter and S is
the formal parameter
now
we will assign as a new value
let's say 30 000.
yeah
here we have assigned as 30 000 earlier
the value of cell was 27 000 and then we
passed the copy of the variable cell
to the function salary there we assign
30 000 to it
so let's print over here
well then
[Music]
foreign
here we have to write s
because the variable name is s
okay now let's try to run this
oh
my God
here we can see value inside function is
30 000.
and value inside main is 27 000.
here we can see the value of the
variable that is passed gets changed but
the original value inside the main
function doesn't changes
so we can say changes are not reflected
to the original value which happens in
call by Value method
so now let's do one example of call by
reference
let's make a new file
called to dot CPU
let's see
hash include
i o stream
now we'll write using namespace standard
now we'll start with int Main
previously now we'll call a function
named increment
and inside the bracket we will pass
the address of cell
as we know that in case of call by
reference we pass the address
so after that we'll just write the
message saying
salary
[Music]
inside
Main
and
we'll write the variable cell
then handle
after that we'll write return 0
now our job is to write the
function
we'll write void
increment
and here
write percent sign s
because here we are passing the address
not any copy of the the
very passing the address of the variable
so that is why percent sign now
we will simply write the logic to
increment so we'll write s equals S Plus
5000 let's say we want the salary to
increment by 5000.
then we will display
the variable s so first of all we'll
write the message
salary
inside
function
the name of the variable after that
handle
now let's try doing this
here we can see that the salary inside
the function is 32 000 and salary
outside
the function that is inside the main
function is 32 000 as well
here we can see that the changes are
reflected to the original values as well
in the main function and we know that in
case of call by reference any change
inside the function is reflected outside
the function because we are passing the
address of the variable
so this is our output 32 000 and 32 000
so these were some basic examples of
call by value and call by reference now
here we will do a program in which we
have to do the sum of two integers with
the help of function
so let's first of all
make a new file
function dot CPP
okay so let's start first of all we'll
declare the header files
that is Hash include Airstream
now the namespace standard
now we will write int Main
now inside admin we'll declare a
variable named s
here we have declared this variable
because we want to store the sum of
those two integers in this variable
so
we'll call the function let's say let's
name the function as sum
and let's
assume the variables to be 5 and 5.
here sum is the name of the function and
5 comma 5 are the arguments now we'll
make the function sum
here end is the return type
sum is the name
and
a comma ENT B
are the parameters
so in this function we'll write the code
to do the sum of these two integers and
for that we have to store the sum in a
variable
for that we will now declare a variable
C
now we will write C equals a plus b
here we are storing the sum of a plus b
into the variable C
now as we know that the return type is
end so we have to return the variable
instead of printing it
will write
return
C
now in the main function
will print that variable
we will print the variable as because
after the function completes its task of
addition the output will come back to
the calling function which is getting
stored in the variable s
so
we will write
the result is
now we will write the variable s
let's see
hope it runs
the result is 10.
five plus five on addition will get 10.
let's write three
and again
try to run this
the result is 8.
5 plus 3 equals to eight so this is the
right answer
now we will do another example of C plus
plus function
in which we have to find the larger
number of Greater number among two
elements
so let's do that
together
let's create a new file
function1.cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include iostream
Now using namespace standard
now first of all we'll write the int
plane
now the variable N1
now we will declare another variable N2
these are the two variables among which
we have to find the greater number
so
will display a message saying that enter
the first number
now we'll take the input
N1
now we will do the same for the other
one
we'll write
enter the second number
we'll input the second number
now
we have to make a call to the function
named let's say maxi
and we will ask these arguments and one
comma into
now let's make this function maxi
the return type is void
maxi
is the name
we'll write the variables N1
and two
now we'll write the if condition because
we have to find the greater number among
both these elements so we'll write the
if condition if N1 is greater than N2
then it must print the n-word
we will also display a message saying
that
the larger number is
foreign
if N1 is greater than N2 then we'll
display the N1
and
if N2 is greater
then we'll display the N2
we'll write the variable N2
so let's see if that runs or not
I think we have to write the first
number here we can see enter the first
number
enter the first number so we'll write
let's say
and the second number would be
the larger number is 78. so
among both the numbers as we know that
70s is greater than 56 so this is how we
can show it with the help of functions
so these were some basic samples of C
plus functions in this video we will be
discussing what is recursion
recursion can be defined as a process in
which a function calls itself again and
again until a certain condition is met
recursion basically brings about several
number of iterative calls to the same
function
however it is important to have a base
case to end the recursion for example
imagine you are calling your friend
again and again for an urgent piece of
work until he picks up the call
now here calling your friend again and
again or one after the other is a
recursive function and when he picks up
your call is the termination condition
and this is the basic syntax where the
function name is recursion and it is
being called from the main function and
inside the recursion function it is
calling itself now let's understand it's
working
there are two parts that is the
recursive case and the base case in the
recursive case the function is being
called by itself again and again and the
base case is when the function finally
stop calling itself
so when the recursive function is called
from the main function then the call
function will execute and it keeps on
repeating as it is being called by
itself from within the function again
and again until it meets the base case
that will terminate its calling
for example factorial of 5. in this
problem we can see a pattern and into
factorial of n minus 1. to be clear n is
5. so n minus 1 is 4. and it is going on
till n becomes 0. here factorial is the
recursive function and N minus 1 is the
argument that is getting passed for
every n into the recursive function in
this case if n becomes 0 or 1
it is the base case and N into factorial
n minus 1 is the recursive condition
now let's understand the types of
recursion
first is direct recursion as the name
suggests in this type of recursion
function calls itself directly for
example void recursion here recursion is
the name of the function and is being
called by itself from within the
function directly although there is no
base case in this example but it shows
the idea of direct recursion
now coming to indirect recursion when a
function calls itself indirectly that is
if a function calls some other function
to make a recursive call then it is
known as indirect function
for example here recursion function is
calling some other function sub
and sub function is calling the
recursion function here both the
functions are calling other functions to
make a recursive call this is called
indirect recursion now coming to
advantages and disadvantages of
recursion the advantages are in
recursion we only need to define the
base case and the recursive case
so therefore it provides a Simple and
Clean way to write a code
second is recursion is more preferred in
problems like tree traversals Tower of
annoy graphs because these are
inherently recursive problems now
disadvantages disadvantages are the
recursive program generally acquires
more space than the iterative program
this is because after every call to the
function each function call will keep on
adding to the stack until the base case
is reached
second is it requires more amount of
time because of function calls now let's
do some examples of recursion on our
code editor that is vs code now here we
will do a program in which we will find
the sum of natural number up to a number
which we will enter and we will do this
example using recursion
so let's start
first of all we'll name this
okay
recursion
dot CPP
okay now we will start with writing
header file that is Hash include
iostream
now we'll add namespace standard
using namespace
STD
now first of all we'll write intman
foreign
so basically we want to enter a number
so for that first of all we'll display a
message saying that enter a number
now we'll take the input
input as num
so now here we will make a call to the
function and in that function we will
pass the variable num which we have
taken the input of and we will print
this with a message
so let's say
we'll print it like C out
and the message would be
sum is
and this is the function name sum
and this is the variable which we are
passing
to that let's write return 0.
now let's make this function some
will write int the return type
sum the name of the function
and
the variable num
now first of all we have to make a base
case
so we will write the base case as
will make if
num
is not equal to 0.
then
here we will write the recursive case
return
num Plus
sum
num minus 1.
foreign
so here we are adding the numbers with
its previous number and because of
recursive condition it will keep on
calling the same function some function
again and again till the base case that
is num becomes equal to 0 is achieved
and once it is achieved the calling
would be stopped
num not equal to 0 here means that if
num is not equal to 0 then only this
statement num plus sum num minus 1
will execute
okay so now after this
will
try to run this
enter the number let's say
5.
sum is 15 here we can see
sum is 15.
okay let's recheck 5 14 14 plus 1 equals
to 15 so our answer is correct so this
is how we can find the sum up to any
numbers which we want to find the sum of
and
now let's do another example
so let's name this as
recursion 2 dot CBP
now here we will do a program of
factorial we will enter a number and we
have to find the factorial of that
number
so let's start
first of all we'll write hash include
are you stream that is the header file
Now using namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
okay now we will declare a variable
number
and we want to take the input from the
user so we'll display a message saying
enter the number
now we will take the input
we'll write number
now we will call a function and we will
send the pass the argument number as we
have done in the previous question
so let's do it
first of all we'll display that
saying
the factorial
of the number
you have entered
is
now we will make a call to the function
let's say the name of the function is
fact
and
will pass the argument number
as we have done previously
now we'll write return 0.
now let's make this function
we will write the in return type int
now fact
after that now we will write the
argument
and number
now we will write if condition
and we'll write
number
less than 1.
and we will return
one
so here we have wrote this condition
because as we know that the factorial of
0 is 1 and if a number is less than 1
that it means it is 0 and if it is 0
then our program should return 1.
and you will write now else condition
else
if it is not 0 that means
we will write the recursive condition
that is
number
into
fact
number minus 1.
now this is the condition that is
responsible for finding the factorial of
a number for example if we input 5 then
here we can see the condition would
become 5 into fact 5 minus 1 that is 4.
and this 4 will be passed as argument to
this fact function and then the
condition would become 4 into fact 4
minus 1 that is 3 and it is also passed
to the function and similarly it will go
on until it becomes less than 1.
now let's try to run this
enter the number
let's say six
the factorial of number you have entered
is 720 and we know that the factorial of
6 is 720 so this is the right answer
and let me tell you this is uh this is
the base case and this is the recursive
case in this program
now after that let's do one last example
of recursion
okay so now let's make a new file
and name this file
now first of all we'll add the header
files
I have stream
now namespace standard using name
space standard
so here we will do the program of
Fibonacci series and we know that
Fibonacci series is basically each num
in Fibonacci series each number is
basically the sum of its two previous
numbers
so let's start so first of all we'll
make int Main
now we'll declare a variable num
now we want to take the input from the
user so first of all we'll display a
message saying that
enter the number
now we'll take the input
we'll write num
now
we will make a for Loop and iterate that
loop from i 0 to num
so we'll write for keyword
int I equal to 0
I less than num
I plus plus
now inside the loop we will write C out
to display and we will call fibo
function and we will pass I as an
argument because we want to print the
series
so we will write C out
fibo
and we'll pass I
as an argument and
just for the space
now we'll write return
zero
in fibo function we have passed is an
argument because we want to print the
series so first 0 will be passed then 1
will be passed after then 2 will be
passed and so on
so now we will make the function fibo
hint is the return type Vivo is the name
now the argument num
now in this fibo function we will put if
condition for checking if the num is
equal to 0 or 1. if yes we will return
the value of num else we will
recursively call fibo using n minus 1
and N minus 2 because Fibonacci series
is basically the sum of previous two
numbers
so first of all we'll write
if
num
is less than equal to 1.
then
return
num
else
return
fibo
num minus 1
Plus
fibo
brackets num minus
because we know
Fibonacci series is basically the sum of
previous two numbers
now if the
num is 0 or 1 then it will go to the if
statement and if it is greater than 0
and 1 then it will go to this recursive
statement
so for example if n equals to 2 then we
will call recursively 2 minus 1 and 2
minus 2 that is 1 and 0 respectively
since 2 minus 1 will give 1 and 2 minus
2 will give 0 these will be evaluated in
if statement as they are less than equal
to 1 so it will give 0 plus 1 that is
equal to 1.
now let's try to run this code
foreign
one one two three five which is the
right answer
the Fibonacci sequence for six is zero
one one two three five
so this is how we can do Fibonacci
series or Fibonacci Sequence with the
help of recursion
and I suggest you to do some more
examples on recursion to understand it
better
moving on why we need header files
header files allows us to assemble all
the predefined functions in one place
and it is helpful because it is easier
to get the Declarations in one place and
then use them whenever we need them
and as all the Declarations are gathered
in one place so it automatically reduces
the complexity and it also decreases the
number of lines of code
there are many functionalities of header
files one of them is it helps in taking
the input from the user and also helps
in displaying the output in a program
now let's learn what actually a c plus
header file is
header files are the set of libraries
that contains predefined functions at a
common place so it basically stores the
Declarations at one common place and
they are being used while writing a
program
these header files usually have a dot h
extension and we use hash include before
writing the header file to inform the
preprocessor that we are including this
header file now let's discuss types of
header files there are two types of
files in C plus first is predefined
header file these files are already
present in C plus compiler we simply
need to import these header files using
hash include which will inform the
compiler about the header file and then
we can write the name of the header file
between the angle brackets
next is user defined header file these
header files are defined or created by
users in C plus plus user can create
their own header file and include it in
the C plus library and it can be used
whenever it is required now let's learn
how to create this header file in order
to create your own header file first of
all we will write the C plus code which
we want to use whenever we want after
that we will save the file with dot h
extension as we can see in Step 1 we
have written the code of two integers
that are getting multiplied
and now we will include this in the
program
to include this in the program we will
use hash include and after that we will
write the name of the header file inside
the angle brackets with the dot h
extension here hash include will inform
the compiler that a header file is added
and now as we can see in Step 2 after
the Declaration of two integers we are
calling the function product and passing
the arguments X and Y
after running this program we will get
the output as 45. because 9 into 5
equals 45 and we don't need to worry
about writing the logic of it because we
have already included this header file
now let's have a look at some examples
of header files
hash include iostream iostream is the
header file that is used to read and
write the standard input output streams
because of this header file we can take
the input and display the output and in
case of iostream dot h is not used
because after standardization of C plus
plus IO stream became standard header
whose function is now in STD namespace
unlike earlier when functions were
defined in iostream before
standardization
next is f stream F stream are associated
with files it is basically used to read
the information from files and write the
information in it
and next is IU manip IO manip is a
library that is used in the manipulation
of input and output statements
so these were some examples of header
files in this video we'll be discussing
about C plus plus array so first is need
of arrays
we use arrays because it allows us to
store similar type of data within
contagious block of memory and it allows
us to iterate through those variables
conveniently using indexing
usually an array is used to store
similar kind of data like marks scored
by all the students of a class and
record of attendance of all the
employees in an organization
now moving to what is an array
an array can be defined as a collection
of similar kind of elements these are
always stored in contagious memory
locations that is one after the other
the total number of elements in an array
is called the length of the array
now this is the way you can visualize
the an array here each block is capable
of storing data values of some type in
sequential Manner and each element can
uniquely identify by its index in the
array
and this is the syntax of array int is
the data type array is the area name and
5 is the size of array
now there are few types of variance C
plus plus
those are
one dimensional two-dimensional array
and multi-dimensional array so let's
first of all discuss 1D array
this is the simplest form of an array in
this array data items are arranged
linearly in one dimension having single
index value to represent data elements
now this is the syntax of 1D array type
is the data type then there is array
name and after that size of array and
this is the example of one dimensional
array
now coming to its memory representation
here we can see two seven four eight one
six are the elements inside the memory
blocks
and 0 1 2 3 4 5 are the indexes
so by using index we can easily access
the elements and once the array elements
are accessed a number of operations can
be performed
here array of 0 means 2 and array of 1
means seven and so on
as each element is of type int that is 2
byte that means the array occupies 12
contagious bytes because each block
contain 2 byte and there are total six
blocks
now coming to the two dimensional array
in this array each element is referred
by two indexes that is rows and columns
and they are stored in the form of
matrices the first index shows a row of
the Matrix and the second index shows
the column of The Matrix now moving to
its memory representation
[Music]
as you can see this is a 2d array with
three rows and three columns and we can
also say that these are basically three
1D array containing three blocks each
combined to form a 2d array in the form
of a matrix with size of 3 cross 3. the
horizontal line step its rows and the
vertical line snap its columns
and we know that index starts from 0 so
first elements get stored at array 0 0
that is 0 through and zero column then
second element is stored at array 0 1
that is zeroth row and column 1 and
likewise all the elements are stored in
the array now coming to the
multi-dimensional array
[Music]
these are defined as area of arrays that
means each element of multi-dimension
array is an array itself they can have
any number of dimensions and it stores
the data in tabular form
a two-dimensional array is also a
multi-dimensional array
and this is the Syntax for a
here type is the data type of array then
array name is the name of the array and
size 1 size 2 up to so on size n are the
dimension of sizes
after that this is the basic example of
a multi-dimensional array
now coming to the next topic that is air
initialization
so there are two ways to initialize an
array in C plus first is you can
initialize an array when you declare it
by including the initial values in
braces after the Declaration
while declaring we could use curly
braces to set the values inside it
for example in this array of size 6 the
element 2 is at 0 index 5 is at one
index one is at 2 index and so on
if we don't mention the size of array
then the array will only be large enough
to hold the elements added within the
curly braces
other than this we can set the value
after the Declaration by assigning the
element to the array using its index
like array of 0 equal to 5
here we are assigning 5 to index 0 and
array of 1 equal to 7 here we are
assigning 7 to index 1 and same goes for
the array of 2. now let's do some
examples on array to understand them
better we'll do these examples on our
code editor that is vs code now we'll
make a new file
and let's name that file as
array.cppu
array1.cpp
now we'll do a basic example in which we
have to print
the elements of array
so let's start first of all we'll write
the header file
[Music]
Dash include ifstream
Now using namespace standard
foreign
[Music]
now we'll start by writing the data type
int now we'll write the array name that
is let's say coupon
and now the size of array
let's say 6.
now curly braces now inside these curly
braces we'll write those elements
let's say five
eight seven
[Music]
three
nine
one
so these are those elements and this is
a array declaration
now
here int means the data type coupon is
the array Name six is the size of array
and five eight seven three nine one are
the elements of array now after that
we'll write the for loop with four
keyword
now we'll initialize I with 0
I less than 6 because it is the size of
array
now we'll increment I
now in this Loop all we have to do is to
print this array so how do we do that
so let's do c out
[Music]
and inside the bracket we'll write I
so here we have printed the array inside
the loop and we have put I inside the
array bracket
now the loop will run from i 0 to 6 and
likewise all the elements from 5 to 1
will get printed so let's see
let's fly to run this code
[Music]
so this is our output
587391 so this is how we can print the
elements of an array
and if we want to print a particular
element from the array all we have to do
is to write the index number of that
element inside the bracket let's say if
we want to print seven
[Music]
all we have to do is to print its index
number that is 2.
now let's run this
C 777 it is because of the loop that
from i 0 to I6 that is why it is getting
printed six times
now if we remove the loop and try to
print it then it will get print only one
time
let's see
here seven
and this is what we want to print
now let's do another example
let's name this file
array2.cbt
foreign
now in this example all we have to do is
to do the sum of all the elements of the
array
so let's start by writing our header
file
stream
[Music]
Now using namespace STD
now we'll write into me
now here first of all we'll declare a
variable sum and initialize it with 0.
[Music]
now we'll declare another variable n
and N will depict the size of the array
so first of all in order to scan array
first of all we have to scan the size of
it
so we'll scan and
[Music]
now we'll declare the array
and inside the bracket we will mention n
because it is the size
foreign
for Loop
and we will initialize with I equals 0.
I less than n which is the size of array
and we'll increment I plus plus we are
writing for Loop here because we want to
scan the array and as in this array
there are more than one element so that
is why we need four loops
so now we will scan the array
we'll write C in
the name of array
and inside the bracket we'll write I
now here we have written I inside the
brackets because we want to take input
of elements from I equal to 0 to n which
is the size of area
now
we'll take another for Loop
now here we will write another for Loop
in which we are initializing I from 0 to
n and inside that for Loop we will do
the sum of the array
so we'll write
equals to zero
I less than n which is the size
now we will increment I plus plus
now inside this for Loop
we'll do the code we'll do the logic of
adding the elements of the array
we will write sum as we know that we
have already initialized sum with 0
we'll write sum equals to sum
Plus
periophyte
now for this statement sum equals to
some plus array of I we are adding each
value in the array one by one into the
sum which is initially 0. when I equals
to 0 then the sum will be equal to 0
plus array of 0 and this sum will keep
on getting stored inside the variable
sum as our I increments or sum keeps on
storing the addition value
now we'll print this sum
outside the loop
we'll write C out
and we will write sum is
foreign
[Music]
let me tell you return 0 is optional in
C plus plus basically return value is
exit status of the program and 0 is
considered as okay in C plus plus
compiler includes it automatically but
it's a good practice
here we forget to write the data type
[Music]
now we'll try to run it
so first of all we'll write the size
like
let's say six
now the elements of the array
let's say one
two three four
five and six
now we want to find the sum of these
elements
[Music]
sum is 21 let's recheck 1 plus 2 equals
to 3 3 plus 3 equals six six plus four
ten
ten plus five fifteen fifteen and six is
twenty one so this is our right answer
so this is another basic example of
array
so after this we'll do one example of
two Dimension array also
so let's make a new file
and we'll write the header file
let's name this file as
array3.cpp
now namespace standard
now we'll write in
T now we will declare a 2d array of
three rows and three columns with
elements inside it
three rows
and second bracket will write three
columns
now we'll write the curly braces
and another curly braces
this is the way to declare a 2d array
now to
seven
nine let's say
now again curly braces
one three
eight because we are creating a matrix
of 3 cross 3
that is why there are total nine
elements inside the array
so now we will create a nested for Loop
where the outer loop IE which is for the
rows of Matrix is initialized from 0 to
2.
we'll write int I equal to 0
now I Less Than 3
I in the space increment
now we will write inner for Loop J which
is for the column and we will initialize
it from 0 to 2 as well
we'll write for
int J equals 0
J Less Than 3
J plus plus
now we will print the array
in the first bracket we will mention I
that is the number of rows and in the
second bracket we will mention J that is
number of columns
and in order to add space
we will add
space in the output
now
outside the bracket we will mention
handle
shift the elements to the next line
after that we'll write it 0.
so this is our output five four one two
seven nine one three eight in The Matrix
form that is why I have used this space
to make the output look good and this
handle
so this is our output 541279138
so this is how we can print the elements
of a multi-dimensional array or two
dimensional array moving on to what is
the pointer pointer can be defined as a
variable that contains the address of
another variable it basically stores the
memory address which means it points to
an address of a particular value
and like a regular variable pointers
have a data type also now coming to
reference and D reference operators
reference operator or address of
operator is defined as that operator
which is used to get the address of the
variable
it can be easily obtained by preceding
the name of the variable within
Ampersand sign
now D reference operator D reference
operator basically Returns the content
stored in the variable pointed by the
specified pointer
for example if we write asterisk a then
it will return the value of variable
pointed by a now let's see how to
declare and initializer pointer to
declare a pointer first of all we will
write the data type
after that we will write the name of the
variable with an asterisk sign for
example int asterisk sign a float
asterisk B care asterisk C
suppose if we want to store the address
into a pointer then we will write int
that is the data type then PTR that is
the name of the pointer
with an asterisk sign equals to a
variable a with Ampersand sign which
means PTR will contain the address of
the variable a
now moving to a pointer arithmetic
C plus plus allows us to perform
addition and subtraction operations on
pointers a pointer is basically an
address that is it's a numeric value
therefore operations like addition
subtraction can easily be done on
pointers
there are four types of arithmetic
operations that can be used in pointers
that is increment Operator decrement
Operator addition and subtraction
each time a pointer is incremented by 1
it points to the memory location of the
next element
but if the pointer is an integer pointer
its value on PTR plus plus would
increment by 4 bytes because of the size
of indata type
for example assume an integer pointer
with current value of 10. now after the
increment its value would be 14 instead
of 11 because int is of 4 bytes now
let's learn about pointers and functions
like a normal variable has an address
similarly every function has an address
also and we can easily access the
function using its reference or address
only if we know the address of the
function
function pointers are similar to that of
normal pointers when pointers are passed
to the function the address of actual
arguments in the calling function is
copied into the formal arguments of the
called function
and this is the Syntax for a declaration
of function pointer
here int is the return type and
parenthesis around function pointer
tells the compiler that it is a pointer
2 function and after this they are
argument lists now let's discuss
pointers and arrays
arrays and pointers are very closely
related to each other and both of them
are objects
when an array gets declared the compiler
assigns a continuous block of memory so
that all the elements of an array can be
stored in the memory
and C plus plus treats the name of the
array as a pointer that contains the
address of first element
which is known as Base address so
basically array name is the Base address
of the array
and if we have to sign the address so
first element of array in a variable X
then instead of writing x equal to
Ampersand array of 0 we can simply write
the name of the array only now moving to
the last topic that is array of pointers
like in Array we can store similar type
of elements it is same in case of array
of pointers but the only difference is
instead of storing the elements the
address of similar type of element is
stored
in other words it stores the pointers
which point to the similar data type
and this is the syntax first is data
type then name of array with an asterisk
sign then in the brackets it is the size
of array now let's do some examples in
our code editor that is vs code if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
here we will do one example of pointer
to understand reference and dereference
operator
we will print the values of variable and
the address of that variable also and it
will give us an idea about reference and
reference operator
let's start first of all we'll make a
new file
and name this file as
pointer1.cpp
so first of all we will import the
header file
stream
now we will include namespace template
after that we'll make int Main
and now we will declare a variable
well
and assign it a value let's say 105.
now we will declare a pointer variable
PTR
now we will store the address of the
variable well into the pointer variable
so we will write PTR equals
Ampersand well
now
will display a message
before printing well variable will
display a message saying
value is
value of Val is
now let's see what is the value of PTR
for that we will have to print PTR also
and we'll write
value of
PTR
is
now we will print the pointer variable
PTR also
although the value of well and PTR would
be same but in order to check we will
print that also
so we'll write
see out
value of
s26 PTR
is
now as we have printed variable Val
PTR and asterisk PTR so now let's check
all these values
next question will be right return 0.
now let's check all these values
here we can see value of variable Val is
105.
and the value of PTR is this this is
actually the address
and the value of pointer variable PTR is
105 as we know that the value of VL and
the pointer variable is same because we
have assigned this value the address of
variable well to PTR
and then the D reference operator
as we know Returns the actual content of
the variable so that is where the value
of variable well gets printed when we
print the pointer variable PTR
and the address over here
is the address of the Val variable which
we are assigning to the PTR
so that is why this address is getting
printed
another example let's name it
pointer2.cpp
now we'll include the header files
hash include iOS stream
after that using namespace standard
so here we have an example of arithmetic
operations in C plus plus so first of
all we'll write int Main
now here we will take four variables and
two pointers
so let's do it
and num1
command number two
and
sum equals 0 and end sub
equals 0 will initialize it with zero
now I will declare the pointers
ptr1
ptr2
so let's take input of the required
variables num1 and num2 and after that
we'll do some mathematic operations on
them
so let's just write
first we'll display a message
enter two numbers
enter
two numbers
now we'll take the input
after this we will store the address of
num1 and num2 into ptr1 and ptr2
respectively let's do it
ptr1
ampersand
num1
ptr2
ampersand num2
foreign
pointer ptr1 and ptr2
we'll do in a bracket and we'll use D
reference operator also
ptr1 plus plus
D reference operator
etr2
plus plus
here we are using the reference operator
because we want to increment the value
only
and as we can see we have used increment
operator so by incrementing ptr1 and
ptr2 the values of num1 and num2 will
increment and after that we will print
those values
so let's do it
before printing we'll just print a
message
after increment
now we will print
ptr1
and line
now ptr2
foreign
now we will do the sum of these
incremented values so we will write sum
equals
D reference operator PTR one
Plus
D reference operator ptr2
now we will simply print it
we'll write addition
and we'll print some variable
which we have already initialized as 0
earlier
and we'll write end line
so this will give us the sum of the
incremented values of num1 and num2
now let's talk about decrementing the
value of pointers using decrement
operator
hereby using this operator the value of
the ptr1 and ptr2 gets decremented so
let's start
document PTR one
minus minus
that is the decrement operator
now
ptr2
and S minus
now we will write
after decrement
the values of ptr1 and ptr2
so we'll display a message saying
after decrement
now we will print ptr1 and ptr2
this will display the values of ptr1 and
ptr2 after decrement
and at last we will find the subtraction
of 2.
so we'll write sub
decrement operator ptr1 minus decrement
operator ptr2
and see how
will display first subtraction will
write subtraction
then we'll write the variable sub
let's see how it before that I think
before going to mention the D reference
operator
while printing
we have to mention this because we want
to print the values
D reference operator
and let's put some space over here
now let's try
enter two numbers so let's say We'll
enter four
and five
as you can see we have entered 4 and 5
after increment it becomes 5 and 6 and
on addition it becomes 11 after
decrement it becomes 4 and 5 again
then 4 minus 5 that is equal to minus 1
so this is the right answer and this is
how it's done this was the basic example
of arithmetic operations in pointers
now let's do another example
name this file as pointer3.cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include
bio stream
using namespace standard
now we'll write intman
now we will do an example of pointer and
arrays in which all we have to do is to
print an array with the help of pointers
so let's start
first of all we will declare a pointer
now we'll declare an array
named a r r a y
and let's add some elements inside it
five
[Music]
sorry 20
4 6.
I think these are seven elements
now we will assign array ARR to pointer
PTR so we'll write PTR equals ARR
after that we'll run a loop from I equal
to 0 to I less than 7 because we want to
iterate array elements so let's write
for Loop and I equals 0 I less than 7 I
plus plus
now we will display
using D reference operator with pointer
because we want to display the values
that is why we have used the reference
operator
now we'll do PTR plus plus
we have used PTR plus plus because we
want the pointer to move to the next
position after each iteration
and endl will help to print the output
in the next line after each iteration
so after this we'll write
return 0.
and let's try to run it
I think there is some error
yeah
namespace
now let's again try to run it
instead of array we have used ARR
hope it works now
here it is
5 17 27 946 so these are our array
Elements which you want to print so this
is how we can print the array elements
with the help of pointer
so these were some basic examples of
pointers in C plus plus let's go ahead
and have a look at what is memory
management
memory management can be defined as a
process in which management of a
computer's memory occurs for example
assigning memory to programs variables
Etc in such a way that it doesn't affect
the overall performance
sometimes the computer's data can range
up to terabytes so efficient use of
memory is necessary so that we can
minimize the memory wastage and boost up
the performance
now let's understand why we need memory
management in C plus plus
memory management is required so that
there will be no wastage of memory and
to make sure that allocation take place
efficiently
during the Declaration of an array there
are times when the correct memory is not
determined until runtime
and avoid such cases we usually declare
array of maximum size and because of
this maximum size some Memory Remains
unused
for example let us suppose we have
declared an array of size 30 and after
declaring the array it turns out that we
only need space of 10 size
so the rest of the space is of no use or
we can say it will get wasted
to avoid such cases we use memory
allocation
so let's understand memory allocation
and deallocation in Z Plus
other programming languages like Java
python Etc they don't need to allocate
memory dynamically
in C language we use the malloc or
Kellogg functions to allocate the memory
dynamically at runtime and these
functions are also supported by C plus
plus but in C plus plus allocation and
delocation is done manually
in C plus plus there are two operators
that are used for the allocation and
deallocation of memory that is new
operator and delete operator
so let's understand this new operator in
C plus plus
the new operator in C plus plus is used
for the dynamic memory allocation
it is used to allocate the memory at
runtime
the general syntax of new operator is
pointer variable which is the name of
the pointer equal to new which is a
keyword and data type is the type of the
pointer
the Syntax for arrays is almost the same
but after the data type we have to write
the size inside the brackets which
specifies the number of elements in an
array
and here in the example we first of all
are declaring a pointer PTR of n data
type
after that we are dynamically allocating
the memory using new keyword and at last
we are assigning the value 75 to the
allocated memory
coming to the delete operator
the delete operator in C plus plus is
used for the deallocation of memory
when we no longer need to use the
variable that means the memory is no
longer required then we have to
de-allocate or release the memory using
the delete operator
Syntax for delete operator is
delete keyword with the name of the
pointer variable
the Syntax for arrays is delete keyword
following the empty brackets and then
name a pointer variable
as we can see in the example once the
printing of value is done
we have de-allocated the memory using
the delete operator
moving on to the advantages of new
operator
the new operator and delete operator can
be overloaded unlike the malloc function
next is a return type of the new
operator is of the same type for which
the memory was allocated we don't need
to use the typecasting
third is the new operator automatically
computes the size of data object we
don't need to use the size of operator
next is new operator in C plus plus
allows us to initialize object while
creating memory space for them
so these were some advantages of the new
operator
so now let's move on to our code editor
that is vs code to do some examples on
the new operator and delete operator
here we will do an example using new and
delete operator in C plus plus that will
allocate the memory location for three
values and find their average
so first of all
let's
create a file and name this file as
mm1.cpb
mm means memory management so now first
of all we'll include the header files
hash include IO stream
Now using namespace standard
now we'll start with into Main
okay
so first of all we'll create three
pointer variables
so we'll start
hint
star ptr1
and
star ptr2 we are creating three pointer
variables because we have to find the
sum of three variables so that is why we
have to create three pointers also
and
now we have to store the sum of three
variables into some another variables so
we now will create the variable average
okay
now we will allocate the memory
dynamically
using the new keyword so we'll write
ptr1 equals
new
end which is the data type
same we will do for ptr2
equals new keyword
hint
here we are allocating the memory
dynamically with the help of new keyword
new
end
sorry m is there
now we will print the value that is
stored in the memory
but before doing that
as we have allocated the memory so now
we will take the input from the users of
those three variables
of which we have to find the average of
so
will display
enter first number
after displaying this
will take the input from the user write
C in
and using the D reference operator
write ptr1
here we are taking the input from the
user for the first memory location
now we'll take the input of the second
number from the user for that we have to
print the message again
enter the second number
yeah now
we'll take the input
using the dereference operator
with the pointer
now same goes for the third one
enter the
third number
the reference operator ptr3
as we have taken all the three numbers
from the user now all we have to do
is to find the average of these three
numbers as we know that D reference
operator will point to the variable
so that is how we'll get the access for
the variable now we'll write
the variable AVG that is average
we know that D reference operator will
display the value that is pointer
pointing at
so
we are actually adding the values
ptr1
plus d reference operator ttr2
plus T reference operator ptr3
divided by 3
this is how we can find the average
after that
all we have to do is to print the
average
so we'll write
average is
AVG that is the variable
as the result is getting stored in this
variable AVG so we'll print that
variable and once everything is done
once the printing is then we have to
deallocate the memory
and we will deallocate the memory by
writing delete
ptr1
we have to do this for all of these
three pointers read ptr2
because we have allocated the memory for
all of these three pointers so that is
why we have to deallocate for each one
of them
okay now
everything is done and let's try to run
this
here we can see enter the first number
so
let's say
five
we have to find the average of three
numbers so we'll select the easy number
to check whether it is right or wrong
then we'll write five again
now we'll write 2.
as we know this 5 plus 5 equals 10 plus
2 equals 12 and the average of 12 is 4
yeah 3 4S are 12. so this is the correct
output
so first of all we have allocated the
memory over here dynamically then we
have deallocated the memory using delete
ptr1 ptr2 and ptr3
so this is how it's done
so let's do one another example
let's name this as
ram2.cpp
okay
we'll write mm4.cpp
I think two and three are already taken
so we'll start with hash include I have
stream
hash
include
IO stream
then we'll write using namespace
standard
so in this question we'll simply enter
the elements of the array and then we
will display those elements but we will
use new operator and delete operator in
this question
so let's start first of all we'll write
int Main
now inside int main first of all we'll
write the variable size we have declared
the variable size
and this variable size is the size of
the array which we will take as an input
from the user
so
first of all
will display
enter the size
now we'll take the input
size
after that we will declare a pointer
variable
PTR
all right
now here we will allocate the memory for
the complete array so we'll write
PTR
new keyword
int
which is the data type and here size
okay here we are allocating the memory
for the complete array of size that we
will enter
okay now
now we will display
the message saying that enter the
elements
as we have allocated the memory now all
we have to do is to enter the elements
we'll use a for Loop
so we'll start with i equals 0
I less than size
I plus plus
now
we'll write
element
and after this we'll take the input from
the user
for the elements of the array so we'll
write C in
now just like arrays we can do it for
the pointer as well we can write PTR
and just like it is
inside the bracket I
and we can do it
for the output as well
so here we are taking the input of the
elements from the users
now
we have to display those elements
so for that first of all we'll display a
message
elements that you
have entered
now we'll use for loop again
and I equals 0
I less than size
I plus plus
now we'll
print those elements so first of all
we'll write
element
now
PTR
like just we
did earlier ptri
and end line
so that the output looks good
now everything is done we have allocated
the memory then we have taken the input
from the user and displayed the output
now all we have to do is to delete the
operator
so we'll write
delete
the empty brackets
PTR
all right
now everything is done
we have allocated the memory and here we
are deleting the allocated memory
okay
now let's try to run this
here we can see enter the size let's say
four
now enter the elements three
six five seven and here is the output
elements that you have entered
3 6 5 7 that is right but
it is not looking good
let's use slation over here
and now let's again try to run this
enter the size
now 2
9.
here is the space between them now it is
looking good enter elements that you
have entered are two four seven nine so
this is how it's done we have allocated
the memory
to an array of size
of size variable
then we have entered the elements then
we have displayed those elements and at
last we have deallocated the memory
using delete operator
so these were few examples on memory
management C plus plus memory management
you can try some more examples on them
let's go ahead and have a look at why do
we need classes
to understand this we need to know that
C plus plus is an object oriented
language and it also introduces the
concept of real world entities so in
order to describe the real world
entities we need two things and that is
characteristics and functions and the
class is a mechanism of binding these
two methods together in a single unit
also class has its own members like
functions variables Constructors
destructors Etc which are commonly used
in C plus plus and class has an
important role in the concept of
inheritance as well now let's understand
what is a class classes are one of the
most important features of C plus plus
that leads to object oriented
programming
it represents the set of properties that
are common among all the objects of same
type
a class basically represents a group of
similar objects which holds its own data
members and member function together and
this is the basic syntax of a class
first is class keyword which is used to
create class then after that we will
write the name of the class then inside
the name of the class there is access
specifier that can be private public or
protected
after that there is data members that is
the variables and then the member
functions and also class wording must be
surrounded with braces
now let's discuss access modifiers it
basically Grant permission or set the
restriction for data members of the
class
access modifiers in a class are used to
provide accessibility to the class
member for example in a school teachers
are allowed to see the question papers
before the exams but the students are
not allowed to do so
anyone other than teachers cannot access
those questions now we can relate these
teachers to data members of class which
have access and students are outside
functions that do not have the access
so there are three types of access
modifiers
private public and protected
private members can only be accessed
from within the class that means outside
data members and member functions cannot
access it
public as the name suggests it can be
accessed from within the class and from
outside the class as well
protected members can be accessed from
within the class but cannot be accessed
from outside the class but with the help
of friend function it can be accessed
from outside the class as well
now let's learn about object of a class
an object is an instance of a class it
is a real word entity that contains
State and behavior
when we create an object of a class then
the memory is allocated and no memory
allocation occurs when class is defined
and we can create as many objects of a
class as we need
in this example state is the class and
St is the object name or reference
variable
so this is how an object is created now
coming to member functions
member functions are also known as
methods these are as much as part of the
class as the member variables these
member functions can be invoked by
sending messages through an instance of
a class with the help of dot operator
for example if the name of the object is
obj and we want to access a function
named sum then it will be obj dot sum
here obj is the name of the object and
sum is the name of the function
now let's learn about Constructors
Constructors can be defined as a special
type of method that is invoked
automatically whenever an object is
created
its main use is to initialize objects
it doesn't have any return type and a
Constructor has the same name as that of
the class
and it is of two types parameterized and
non-parameterized
the Syntax for parameterized Constructor
is class name which is a Constructor
name and then arguments inside the
bracket
in non-parameterized Constructor the
syntax is class name
with empty brackets as there are no
parameters in non-parameterized
Constructors
now after Constructor let's discuss the
destructor also
Destructor as the name suggests is also
a special method that destroys or
destructs the object as soon as the
scope of the object ends
and it is automatically invoked when the
object goes out of the scope
its name is same as that of the class
but with the tilde sign
here is the syntax of Destructor
till the sign with Constructor name or
class name and then empty brackets
now to do some examples on classes let's
move on to our code editor that is vs
code now here we will make a new file
let's name this file as
class.cpp
now here we will do a program in which
we will make a class and inside that
class we will make some functions and
with the help of objects of that class
we will call those functions
so let's start first of all we'll
mention the header files hash include
iostream
Now using namespace standard
now let's
make a class
and with a class keyword
and name this class as let's say
franchise
now here don't forget to mention the
semicolon
now
here we will write the excess modifier
that is public
now we'll mention those functions
let's say void
let's name this function as KFC
now inside this function
we will print
something like let's say
we have the best chicken
foreign
now we'll make another function named
Burger King
as we know that these two are
famous franchise so that is why we have
put this under class for franchise
now let's
print here we have the best burgers
foreign
these two functions with the help of
object that are made from the class
franchise
so what we'll do is
we'll write end Main
after the franchise class we'll write
int Main and inside this class
will make an object
of class franchise
franchise is the class name friend is
the object name
now all we have to do is the calling
we'll call the function KFC and we'll
call the function Burger King with the
help of friend object
so let's do this
friend dot operator
KFC
that is the function name
after that we'll write friend
Dot
Burger King
return 0.
now let's try to run this one
here it is actually I have run it twice
so that is why it is again getting
printed twice we have the best chicken
we have the best burgers that is what we
want to print
first here friend dot KFC call this void
KFC inside this class franchise after
that friend.berger King call this
function Burger King so that is why they
have printed serial wise we have the
best chicken we have the best burgers
after this we'll do another example
so let's do this
first of all we'll name this file
class
Class 2 dot CPP
okay I think it already exists
we have to name it something else
three
okay now we will write
the header files
hash include ifstream
Now using
namespace standard
foreign
we will try to access a private variable
as we know that it can only be accessed
from within the class but it can be done
with the help of segregator methods
so let's start first of all we'll write
hint Main
now we'll
make an object
for that we have to write the class name
which is
billboard
will make this class afterwards
first of all we'll write the class name
after that we'll write object
let's name the object Bill Billboard is
class name Bill is the object name
now we will call
a particular method or a function
which we call Setter method we will
write
bill
dot will name that Setter method as set
title
basically this function will access or
assign the value to the private variable
which we were talking about
so we'll write here
let's say top
five songs
of 2020.
we want this title to be written on the
billboard
now we'll write the getter method
basically the setter method or set title
method will set or assign the value of
to the private variable and get method
or get title method will return that
value from there
so we'll write Bill Dot
get title
now because we want to print it so that
is why we'll write it
in C out
okay now after that we'll write return
0.
now we will make the class billboard
class keyword
billboard
after that bracket starts
now we will write private
because you want
the variable to private
so
the data type string
and the variable is title
now this variable is private and we want
to assign the value to this variable
which is not possible because they are
not of the same class but we will do
that with the help of ceterogator method
so let's do that
now we will write public
because we want our functions to be
public
now void that is the data type
set title
and inside the bracket we'll write the
variable
now this method is taking this very this
parameter X so we'll assign this
parameter x to the private variable
let's do that
title that is the private variable
X
now
we will write another method named get
title
there are no parentheses in get title
method because this method is only
returning the value so we'll write
return
title
now get title function or method is
returning the value of private variable
title so here what happening is here the
function set title which is public is
taking a parameter X and is assigning to
the title variable
so the message will get assigned to the
title variable now get title function is
returning the value of private variable
title
which is getting called in the mean
function
one more thing we forgot to
put semicolon over here
and
we get title cannot be void
because it is returning
it would be string
because it is returning some value
now
so basically build.set title in the main
function will set the value or assign
the value to the private variable and
build dot get title will return the
value of that private variable which
will get printed
so now let's try to run this
[Music]
top 5 songs of 2020 here we can see
it is getting printed
so this is how we can do that we can
access the private variable using Setter
and getter method
now let's do another example
let's name this as
class 4 dot CPP
now here we will do the same example but
we will do it with the help of
Constructors
so let's continue first of all we'll
write hash include iostream
after that using namespace standard
now here first of all we'll write int
Main
now we will name the class we'll write
the name of the class that is billboard
and we'll make the object of it
as we have done previously like Bill
now we'll make a Constructor of this
object
and we'll pass the parameters
we'll pass the string as
top three
songs
of 2020
as we are passing the string to the
Constructor that means the Constructor
is parameterized Constructor and now
we'll write Bill Dot get title
here we are writing this because
function this function is returning the
value of private variable title so that
is why we have to write it
and we'll print it actually
see out
return 0.
now let's do the other thing
as we have done previously we'll write
class
billboard we are making this class
and inside this class we are making the
variable private
string title is private
now we'll write Public Access modifier
now here we will write the Constructor
in which we were passing the string from
the main function so we'll write the
name of the Constructor as you all know
the name of the Constructor is same as
that of the class so it would be
billboard
and
the parameter is
B
that parameters which we are passing
from the main function is getting stored
in b
now inside this Constructor we'll call
the method set title
so we'll write set
title
we are passing the same string to the
set title method
now
we'll make this method
set title we'll write
void
set title
string a
so actually what is happening we have
passed a string named top three songs of
2020 to the Constructor The Constructor
is further calling to the method or
function named set title and is passing
that string to the same function
now that function is set title and now
we will assign that string to the
private variable title
so let's write
title equals a
is that string
now
as we have done previously we'll write
void get title
now get title function is used for
returning the value of private variable
as we know so we'll write
string actually
string get title
return
title
semicolon
now let's try to run it
I think something is wrong
here capital S we have written
let's make it correct
now let's try to run again
here we can see top three songs of 2020.
so this is how we can print with the
help of Constructor
this was the same example as that of the
previous one but to understand
Constructors we have done this with the
help of Constructors and we get the
right output
so after this we'll do the example of
destructors
okay let's name this
as class six
dot CPP
now let's write the header files
include
i o stream
using namespace standard
now we'll start with int Main
so first of all we will write the class
name that is Gambit
to access the class we need to have an
instance or object of class here the
name of the object is gan
after this we will call a function
display so we will write
again dot display
return 0
now let me tell you what is happening
so as we declared this object
Constructor will be called that is
Gambit and the message inside the
Constructor will be printed
after the Constructor gets completed we
will return back to the main now we have
game dot display which is used to call
display function inside the Gambit class
so after this we will write the class
let's make it
class keyword
Gambit
now we'll write Public Access modifier
foreign
The Constructor
and inside the Constructor will display
the message
we'll write hello
hello there
I am Constructor
I am in Constructor
now here we will write the destructor
foreign
and inside the destructor we will print
the message
just to indicate that we are in the
destructor
hello there
I am in Destructor
foreign
but before that we have to
write the function display also so we'll
write
void
display
and we'll print the message
let's say hello
now let's try to understand this again
as the object is declared constructed
will be called that is Gambit and the
message inside the Constructor will be
printed after the Constructor gets
completed we will return back to the
main now we have gam.d display which is
used to call display function inside the
Gambit class
so hello will be printed
now as we can see the program has
finished the execution now the
destructor will be called and hello I am
Destructor will be printed
as we know Destructor destroys the
object at as the scope of the object
ends so after the scope of the object
ends hello I am in Destructor gets
printed in the last
so now let's try to run this
here we can see
hello there I am in Constructor
then hello is printed then hello there I
mean Destructor is printed as we have
thought
Destructor is getting printed in the
last because as we know that when the
scope ends the destructor is called
so these were some basic examples of
classes in C plus plus now let's move on
to Y oops
well there were some limitations in
earlier approaches to programming and
oops help to fill those gaps
in object oriented programming it is
easy to maintain the code with the help
of classes and objects and with the help
of inheritance there is code reusability
that is we don't have to write the same
code again and again which increases the
Simplicity of the program
now let's understand what is object
oriented programming
object oriented programming is a
programming pattern where the programs
are structured around objects rather
than logic and functions in other words
we basically focus on objects that are
required to be manipulated instead of
logic
for example let us suppose we have made
blueprint of a mole then that blueprint
will be a plan that explains what
properties the mall should have and how
it should look like Etc
but it is just a blueprint of the mall
we cannot go inside it physically as of
now
now the constructors will go through the
blueprint and they will construct them
all and they can make as many malls as
they want with the help of that
blueprint and each Mall can have its own
different shops and showrooms in this
case blueprint is the class the mole is
the object and the show-ups and
showrooms inside the malls are data
stored in the object's properties and
these are some basic concepts of oops
first is classes then objects then data
abstraction and encapsulation then there
is inheritance polymorphism Dynamic
binding and message passing we will
learn about these Concepts later first
we will discuss the difference between
oops versus procedure programming
procedural programming follows top-down
approach a top-down approach means
fragmenting a bigger complication into
smaller chunks
oops follows bottom-up approach and
bottom-up approach means piecing
together smaller tasks to give rise to
complex tasks
in procedure programming overloading is
not possible in oops overloading can be
done
in procedural oriented programming there
are no access specifiers in oop they
have access specifiers like private
protected public
procedural oriented programming is less
secure oops is more secure because of
the concepts like abstraction and
encapsulation which are used for data
hiding
now let's learn the basic concepts of
oops
first is class
can be defined as collection of objects
it is a logical entity
then there is object it is defined as an
entity that has State and behavior or in
other words anything that exists
physically in the world is called an
object
inheritance can be defined as when one
object acquires properties and behavior
from its parent class
it provides code usability
polymorphism polymorphism is a
combination of two words poly which
means many and morphs which means forms
it is basically an ability to exist in
more than one form
next is abstraction
hiding the internal details and showing
the functionality to the user is called
abstraction
then encapsulation encapsulation is The
Binding of code and data together into a
single unit
in Dynamic binding
Dynamic binding is the method called at
runtime that means which code will
execute is unknown until the program
runs then there is message passing
it is basically a communication that
exists between the objects
as we have gone through some concepts of
whoops now let's discuss some benefits
of oops in oops code can easily be
reused with the help of inheritance and
object
we don't need to write the same code
over and over
second is with the help of abstraction
and encapsulation certain parts of
program can be hidden and it helps to
make a secure system
third is maintaining and modification of
code is easy in object oriented
programming
now to do some examples on the concepts
of oops let's move on to a code editor
that is vs code
now here we will do a program of
inheritance in which we will make a
parent class and a child class and we
will call the attributes using object of
child class
so let's get started first of all
let's name the file
poop dot CPP
okay so first of all We'll add the
header files
hash include
higher stream
now adding namespace standard
now we will write int Main
so we want to create the object of child
class so first of all we'll write the
name of class child that is child
let's put C capital
child and now the name of the object ch
so now we will call the attributes using
this object so we'll write first of all
displayed so we'll write C out
CH dot name
one
which is the attribute we will declare
it later
foreign
so basically we want to write both the
names of both the classes together so
that is why
we are doing like this we'll write name
two
name one will be the attribute of the
parent class and name two will be the
attribute of child class
so after that we'll write
return 0.
now
we'll make the parent class and the
child class so first of all let's write
class
parent will name it as parent
then
we'll write Public Access specifier
string is the data type
name one
let's write
um
Harley
okay now
it is mandatory to write the semicolon
at the end of the class
now
we'll write the derived class that is
child
we will write the column symbol then we
will write public
name of the parent class that is parent
so here we are writing
the child class is derived from the
parent class
now
within the bracket we'll
write public
then string the data type
name to
we'll write ha Davidson
it's a popular bike brand Harley
Davidson so
now we'll write the semicolon over here
now we will try to run this
[Music]
as you can see Harley Davidson
here Harley is from the parent class and
Davidson is from the child class so as
we can see that we are calling from the
object of child class and still we are
able to access the attribute of parent
class so this shows that the child class
inherits attributes or properties from
the parent class
now as we have done one example of
inheritance so now let's do one example
of polymorphism also
let's name it oop
one dot CPP
first before we'll include the header
files
rash include IO stream
now we'll write using namespace standard
after that we'll write int Main
now here we will do an example of
polymorphism in which we will make a
base class and its derived classes and
inside these classes we will override a
function which is common in all of these
classes
so let's start first of all we'll write
the name of the parent class or Base
Class
animal
and will make an object a
after that we'll write the name of the
child's class cheetah
and its object name is Seal let's say
now
another derived class dolphin
and we'll name the object as d
now while making these classes we'll
write a function name speed in all of
these classes inside all of these
classes and now in order to override
that function we'll call them
so first of all we'll call it by the
object of animal that is a
a DOT speed
now C Dot
speed
this is the object of cheetah class
now D dot speed
after that we'll write return 0
. now let's make these classes
first of all we will make the animal
flash that is the base class
animal
now we'll write the excess specifier
public
now we'll write the function
void that is the data type speed
now we will display a message inside
this function
let's say
it displays who is more faster
who is more
faster
okay
now we'll put a semicolon in the end
now we will make a derived class that is
dolphin
we'll write class
child of
animal class
okay so now inside this class
we'll write public
and we'll make the same function speed
and will display a message
saying
as this class is of dolphin so we'll
write
I am faster
in water
we'll put semicolon
now we'll make another child's class
cheetah
Okay C is capital cheetah
public animal
now here we will write
Public Access specifier
and we'll write the same function wide
speed
and over here we'll display a message
saying that
I am
faster on the ground
semicolon
so now as we can see that a DOT speed is
calling this speed function
in animal class
C dot speed is calling this cheetah
function in cheetah class
and D dot speed
D dot speed is calling the dolphin
speed function in Dolphin class
okay so now let's try to run this
[Music]
okay the output is here but it is not
in very good form so
let's put slash n in the end
okay
slash n
here it is so first who is faster is
displayed then I am faster on the ground
then I am faster in water
is displayed so as we know that first of
all we have called the animal class so
that is why who is more faster is
displayed after that we have called the
cheetah class and cheetah says that I am
faster on the ground then dolphin class
then dolphin says I am faster in water
so
here we can see that each of the class
have its different implementation for
the same function that is speed and this
is how polymorphism allows us to do a
single action in variety of ways
okay now let's do one example of
abstraction
let's name it as
oop three Dot cpb
first of all we'll include the header
files we'll write hash
include iostream
now we'll write the namespace standard
using namespace STD
now as we know abstraction helps in data
hiding so in this program we will make a
variable named coupon as private and
with the help of set coupon function we
will try to assign some value to the
coupon variable
and after that we will display it
so let's start first of all we'll write
int Main
now we'll write the name of the class
that is Trade Fair
Trade Fair
and now the name of the object t
now with the help of this object we will
call a function named set
coupon
I would say coupons
and we'll pass 50 as an argument to this
function
now
we'll display
a message
coupon
and after that
we will call get coupon method in order
to display the number of coupons
so we'll write T Dot
get
coupons
and
brackets
done
after that we'll write return 0.
now let's make the class and the
functions so let's start first of all
we'll write
class
Trade Fair
now we'll write an excess specifier
private
and
I private
now
we will declare a variable coupon
and as I've already told you we will
make this variable as private so that is
why we have used this excess specifier
as private
now
after that we will write Public Access
specifier
to write a function
that is set coupons
set
coupons
and the parameter is c as we know that
we have passed 50 to this parameter so
now
we will write
the private variable coupon
equals c
so here we are basically assigning
the value of C to the coupon that is we
are assigning 50 to coupon
variable now
after that
we will make another function
and we'll put its data type as int
because it is returning something
so we'll write int get coupon
and we will return
variable coupon
now as the class ends we will write
semicolon
now let's try to run this code
there is some error
okay we haven't tried s over here
now let's again try to run it
coupon 50.
as I have told you
so here we have assigned 50 to this
function and
the variable C is assigning 50 to the
variable coupon
now after that we have used get coupon
function to return the value of coupon
and that is why it is getting displayed
over here
so we got our answer that is coupon 50.
and as you can see that in this example
we are not allowed to access the
variable coupon but still somehow we
have managed to do that with the help of
some functions so this is an example of
abstraction and
it helps to increase the security of the
program
so this these were some basic examples
of oops in C plus plus let's go ahead
and have a look at what is operator
overloading operator overloading is a
special case of polymorphism in which
the operator is overloaded to provide
special meaning to the user defined data
type basically it adds some features or
redefines the functionality of already
existing operators for example let us
suppose we have three objects of same
class namely a b c
and C equals a minus B
now here we can redefine how minus
operator works and we can write C equals
a minus b instead of writing C equals to
a DOT subtract B
and this is the general syntax of
operator overloading
first is the return type of the function
after that operator is the keyword then
symbol is the operator we want to
overload then the arguments are those
which are passed to the function
now let's move on to the non
overloadable operators
there are some operators in C plus plus
that cannot be overloaded because it is
not syntactically possible to overload
them
first is the dot operator the next is
scope resolution operator and third is
pointer to member operator and at last
we have ternary operator
coming to the next topic that is types
of operator overloading in C plus
so there are two types of operator
overloading that is Unity operator
overloading and binary operator
overloading
first is unary operator overloading
it is defined as an operator which
contains only one operand or works on
only one operand
increment operator and decrement
operator are examples of it
there are two ways to do operator
overloading that is from the class
function and the friend function its
syntax using class function is the
return type operator keyword then the
symbol and the brackets but if we are
doing post fix in the function then we
have to write the data type inside the
brackets
syntax using friend function is friend
keyword return type then operator
keyword after that symbol and in case of
Rand function we have to pass an
argument
next is binary operator overloading
an operator which contains two operands
or works with two operands is called
binary operator overloading addition
subtraction multiplication are examples
of binary operator overloading syntax
using class function is return type then
operator keyword then the symbol and
then we have to pass an argument inside
the brackets
and syntax using friend function is
friend keyword then the return type
after that operator keyword and then the
symbol and in case of friend function we
can pass two arguments
now we will do one example of unile
operator overloading in which we will
increment the value of the variable with
the help of operator overloading
so now let's move on to our code editor
that is vs code
so here first of all we'll make a new
file
and name that file as operator dot CPP
now first of all we write the header
files hash include
iostream
now we'll write the namespace standard
now we'll start with int Main
and inside intmin first of all we'll
write the name of the class that is
increase
and its object Inc
now we will call the void operator
increment function
so we will write
plus plus I and C
here when we write plus plus Inc then
function void operator plus plus will be
called which we will make later
so as of now first of all we
write I and C dot display in order to
display the output we are calling the
display function over here
now after that we'll write return 0.
now we'll make the class
so we'll write class
increase which is the name of the class
now we'll use the access specifier
private
and we'll write the variable
int value
now we'll write another excess specifier
public
and now we will make the Constructor
because we have created the object Inc
so that is why a Constructor is called
and we are making it
increase
and inside the Constructor we have given
the value 10 to the variable
now
plus plus Inc is calling the void
operator plus plus function so we'll
write that function
void
operator
increment
which is the symbol now value equals
Value Plus 5 because we are incrementing
the variable with five so we'll write
value equals Value Plus 5.
now after that we have to display the
value variable so we will write
void display
because we have already called over here
Inc dot display so now we will write
inside
C out
we'll write the message value
is
now the variable value
and handle
after the class we have to use the
semicolon now let's try to run this
okay
here is our output value is 15.
previously the value was 10 then on
increment its value gets 15 which is the
right output
so here first of all we have created an
object and Constructor is called and
inside the Constructor we have
initialized value with 10.
then with the help of object Inc that is
when we are using plus plus Inc then we
are calling the void operator function
which is increasing the value of the
variable by 5 and then we are displaying
it with the help of display function
and one more thing guys in case of post
fix that is in case of INC plus plus we
have to write the data type inside the
void operator function that is over here
now let's do another example for binary
operator overloading
so let's name this
operator
2 dot CPP
now here we will do one example of
binary operator overloading in which we
will add two complex numbers
so let's start
first of all
let's make the header files
hash include iostream
Now using namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
okay now first of all we will write the
name of the class that is complex
so we'll write
complex
and then the objects like com1
com2
res we have created three object
now we will write a message because we
have to take the input from the user so
first of all write a message
enter first complex number
because we have to add two complex
numbers so first of all we'll take the
input of the first one
that is
slashing
okay now we have to write com1 dot input
input is the name of the function which
we will be creating afterwards
then
C out
enter second complex number
that is
now we'll write slash n
okay
now after this we have to write the
semicolon and we'll write com 2
dot input
these input function will take the input
of complex numbers from the user we will
declare them later we will make them
later
okay now we will now here we will do an
operation with the help of plus operator
function
so we will write
res equals
com 1 plus com 2.
this function call from com1 will go to
the complex of operator plus function
and comb2 will be passed to the argument
obj
and the result will be stored in
variable rest
okay now we will
call another function output in order to
display the output
rest dot output after that we'll write
return 0.
now we will make the class complex
we'll write
class complex
we'll write the access specifier private
and the variables int real
and end
image that is imaginary because we know
in complex number there is a real part
and imaginary part
okay now we'll write Public Access
specifier
and now we will write the function input
in order to take the input from the user
void input
now first of all we have to display a
message
we will write enter real in imaginary
Parts respectively
okay
now we will write
C in because we have to take the input
and the variable name real
and imaginary
now we will write the overloading
function we'll write the return type
that is the complex
then operator keyword
then symbol
then
argument
complex
obj
okay now
we will write
complex
temp
so here we have created the data type
temp of complex class
will make it a Capital C
okay now we will write temp dot real
equals to real plus obj dot real so
we'll write temp
Dot real
equals to
real plus obj dot real
the plus operator over here will add the
real part of the number to the real part
of another number
and similarly we'll do it for the
imaginary part
Right Temp Dot
imaginary
equals imaginary Plus
obj dot imaginary
and
and then the value of the variable temp
is returned so we'll write
return
temp
the value was stored in temp so that is
why we have returned temp
now we will make the output function
we'll write
void
output
right output is
variable real
then
we'll write Plus
then imaginary
and then
I because this is the Syntax for
complex number
okay now we have to put the semicolon
over here
has the value of temp is returned now
the result is stored in variable rest
and then we will print the output using
the output function this is the output
function and the value is stored in
dress and then we are printing the
output using the output function
com1 over here is getting passed to the
complex of operator plus function and
comb2 is getting passed to the argument
obj and the result is getting stored in
rest
now let's try to run this code
the first complex number let's say 2
plus 2 Iota so we will write 2 and 2.
and then enter second complex number
that is enter real and imaginary part
respectively now we have to write the
real and imaginary parts of the second
complex number so we'll write
Plus
um 6 iota
so the output is 6 Plus 8 Iota 2 plus 4
equals 6 and 2 plus 6 equals to 8 so
this is our correct output we are
basically adding two complex numbers
with the help of binary operator
overloading so this is how it is done
so these were some important examples of
operator overloading moving on to why we
use vectors in C plus plus
vectors are used when we are not sure
about the size of data like in case of
arrays we have to guess the size of the
data first because it is not possible to
resize it later
but in case of vectors we don't have to
set the size of vector and it is
resizable that is why it is more
preferable for dynamic elements
and it also has some inbuilt functions
like pushback size empty Etc which helps
in dealing with data values
now let's understand what is a vector
vectors are array like containers that
is used to store data and the data is
stored in contiguous storage locations
but unlike arrays its size can be
changed automatically depending on the
number of elements and it is not
necessary to mention the size of vector
while declaring it
now let's have a look at the syntax here
inside the angle brackets this is the
data type of the vector
it can be string end float Etc and V2 V1
V3 are the names of the vectors
respectively
now let's understand the member
functions of vectors
a vector container has three types of
member functions that is modifiers
iterators and capacity
so let's understand these functions in
detail
first is modifiers
these are those functions that are used
to modify data elements for example
first is pushback function this function
is used to add a new element to the end
of the vector
next is pop back this function deletes
the last element of the vector
then there is insert function it is used
to insert a new element at a specified
position
in this function there are two
parameters first parameter specifies the
position and second specifies the value
after that erase function raise function
is used to remove the elements at a
certain position or to remove a range of
elements
either you can write the position of the
element you want to remove inside the
bracket or you can write starting
position and ending position of the
range of elements inside it
next is swap function this function is
used to swap the contents or elements
between two vectors and if there are two
vectors named V1 and V2
that we want to swap then its syntax
would be V1 dot swap V2
then there is a sine function this
function is used to assign values to the
vector in this function there are two
parameters first one specifies number of
values to be assigned and second
represents the value that is to be
assigned
last is clear function this function is
used to remove all the elements from the
vector
now moving on to iterator functions
these are those functions that helps in
iterating across the elements
first is begin function it basically
Returns the iterator pointing to the
beginning of the vector
the next is end function this function
Returns the iterator pointing to the end
of the vector
foreign now coming to capacity functions
these functions that lie under capacity
are associated with size
so first is size function
this function Returns the number of
elements in the vector
next is Max size function this function
Returns the maximum size that a vector
can hold
then there is resize function this
function changes the size of the
container
and inside the brackets a number n is
mentioned if n is less than the size of
container then content is reduced by
removing extra elements but if n is
greater than the size of the container
then extra elements are added at the end
so that it reaches the size of n
after that capacity function this
function Returns the size that is
currently allocated to the vector
container
at last there is empty function which
checks whether the vector is empty or
not
if it returns true then it is empty and
if false then it is not empty
now to understand these Vector functions
in a better way let's do some examples
of these Vector functions in our code
editor that is vs code
so first of all let's make a new file
and name this file
vector.cpp
now first of all we will write the
header file that is
hash include
i o stream
now we will write the header file hash
include
vector
this is the header file for Vector
because we are doing some examples on
vectors so that is why we have to use it
now we'll write the namespace standard
using
namespace
STD
now we'll start with int Main
now first of all we'll Define the vector
so we'll write vector
and inside the angle bracket we will
write int which is the data type
now the name of the vector will write n
now first of all we'll see the
functionality of assign function
as we know that a sign basically puts
the value at positions
so we will write
and Dot
assign
now first of all
we'll write the number of values like 9
is the number of values
after that in the second parameter we'll
write the value
here it means that we are putting 1 to 9
positions in the vector
that is we are assigning 1 to 9
positions
now in order to print this first of all
we'll
display a message
saying
the contents are
now in order to print these contents
basically we have two
write a for Loop
we'll write tint a
equals zero
will initialize it from 0
then
a less than
n dot size
this is the size function it basically
Returns the number of elements
now
a plus plus will increment
we have to now print this
we have to write like an array in order
to print all the elements
we'll write
n
and inside the bracket a
now we'll leave some space
you will write handle
we wrote handle over here in order to
insert a new line
now after that
we'll see the functionality of one
another function that is pushback
and we know that pushback functions adds
an element at the end of the vector
so we will write n Dot
pushback
and then the element which we want to
add like let's say two
now
we have to display this last element
also so in order to display this we will
store the size of Vector in some
variable and then we will print the last
element
so we will write
int
and no
this is the variable name
then we will write and Dot size
here we are storing the size of the
vector in some variable and no
now
will display
last element
will display the message saying last
element
foreign
the last element and as we know in order
to print the last element we have to
print the N minus 1 element so we will
write an bracket and no minus 1.
here we are writing an bracket
and no minus 1.
this will print the last element
after that we'll write handle
now after that we will see another
function that is pop back it basically
removes the last element so we'll write
n
pop underscore back
so this function will remove the last
element that we have added that is 2.
so we need to print this also so we'll
write
first of all we'll display a message
now the contents are
foreign foreign
Loop
as we have done previously
we'll write int a equals zero
a less than
n dot size
a plus plus
now we'll again print
in the form of array
sorry
and and inside the bracket we will write
a
then in order to give some space we'll
write this
after this we'll write angle
to add one new line
so firstly we displayed the contents
then we added one element at the end and
then displayed that element after that
we have removed that element with the
help of popback function
as you have noticed that we are just
doing the functions of modifiers yet so
in this example we will cover some
functions of modifiers only then in the
next examples we will do for iterator
functions and then for the capacity
function
so now let's do the functionality of
insert function
as we know that insert function is used
to add an element at a specified
position so we will write n Dot
insert
n dot begin
it will point to the first element
then 7.
as we know that the first parameter
specifies position and the second
specifies the value so n dot begin will
point to the first position and 7 is the
value
so now we will print it also
we'll write
first element
is
then we will write
display the first element
then we'll write handle
now we will use the function clear
to remove all the elements we'll write n
dot c l e a r clear
and then in order to check
we will write n dot size so first of all
we'll write now
the size is
and in order to check whether it is
whether all the elements are removed or
not we'll write n dot size
it will display the size
the program is pretty long but let's
just hope it runs
here it is
now the contents are last element
let's have a look whether it is right or
not
one is displaying nine times then last
element we have added two
then we have removed that element
it is also correct then the first
element we have added using insert 7 is
there and after using clear function
now the size is zero so this is the
correct output
now after doing this function let's try
another example
now here we will do the example of
iterator functions in which first of all
we will add some elements inside the
vector and then we will print them using
iterators
so let's start
first of all name this
vectors
2 dot CPP
now first of all we'll write the header
file
hash include iostream
then the header file for vectors hash
include
vector
then
we'll use namespace standard
now we'll start with int Main
so here we will write vector
and inside the angle brackets we'll
write the data type that is int
and then the name of the vector that is
num
now we will write the for Loop and with
the help of for Loop We'll add the
elements inside the vector one by one
so we will write for
int
I equals 0
I less than
let's say 5
I plus plus
let's make it 1 over here
okay now
after that
will push these elements one by one
inside the vector so we'll write the
function
pushback we'll write num Dot
push back
and here I will write I
okay now
because we want to add the elements from
1 to 5 so that is why we have to use
less than equal to because we want to
include 5 also
okay now
we have to print these elements right so
we'll write
first of all we'll display
that output
from the begin
to the end
okay
now
now we will write for Loop and with the
help of iterators we will print the
elements of vector
so we'll write
photo this is the iterator and
a is the iterator name
then we'll write num Dot
begin
as we know that begin function points to
the
first element of the vector so that is
why we have written num dot begin
now we will write
a less than
sorry not equal to
num Dot
and
then a plus plus
now after that we have written a naught
equal to num Dot N and we know that n
function Returns the iterator to the end
of the vector
and after that we have used increment
operator
so this Loop will run from beginning
till it reaches to the end and inside
for Loop we will write the D reference
operator with a so that each element
which is getting pointed by a will
display one by one with the help of loop
so let's write
we'll write
C out
D reference operator a
and then we'll give some space
now let's try to run this
[Music]
this is the output output from the
beginning to end
one two three four five this is our
right output this is the message which
we want to display and this is the
output one two three four five which you
want to display which we have added in
the vector and then we have displayed
so now let's do
another example which includes the
capacity function
so
we'll make another file
Vector 3 dot CPP
so in this example we will add some
elements in the vector and then we will
apply some functions on it
so let's start
first of all we'll include the header
file
hash include iostream
then
the header file for vectors hash include
vector
then we'll write the namespace standard
using name
space STD
foreign
so first of all we'll write vector
and then the data type
and then the name of the vector let's
say V
now one by one we'll put some elements
inside the vector so we'll write for
Loop
we'll start with int x equals 0
X
less than equal to 10.
X plus plus
because we want to add these elements
so we will write V Dot
push back
and then we will write X inside the
brackets
semicolon
now here one by one all the elements
from
0 to 10 will be added let's make it one
to ten
okay now
we will apply some functions on this
vector
so let's first of all try out the size
function so first of all we'll write
Vector size
is
and then we'll write the function V Dot
size
and then we'll write
handle
so this function will tell us the size
of the vector because we have already
added the elements from 1 to 10 so it
will display 10
after that we will use the try out the
capacity function
we'll write
capacity of vector is
and then we will write V Dot
capacity
oh
after that here also we'll write endl
now
we will use the maximum size
or the max size so we'll write
maximum
size
of
Vector is
so in order to calculate the maximum
size we write V Dot
Max
underscore
size
handle
As We Know That V Dot size will give us
the size of the vector and capacity
function this function Returns the size
that is currently allocated to the
vector container
and Max size this function Returns the
maximum size of the vector
so all of these functions
result will be displayed because we have
wrote them inside C out
now
let's try another function
that is resize
now in order to resize the vector we'll
write V Dot
resize and then we'll write
the number that we want to resize it
with like let's write five
now in order to check this also we will
display
so we'll write
Vector size
after resizing
resizing is
I forgot to put the commas
okay now we'll write
V Dot size because now we want to find
the size after resizing
so we have written V Dot size
now
after that
we will write NL
okay
now we'll try the empty function
we'll put empty function inside if
now inside if we'll write V Dot empty
equals equals false
it means
if the vector is not empty because we
have written V Dot empty equal equal to
false not true we have written V Dot
empty equal to equal to false that means
if it is not empty then
will display
Vector is not empty and in else
condition we will write Vector is empty
so here we will write
C out
back
again I forgot to put over here
okay
vector
is not empty
and in else condition
foreign
Vector is empty
so in this question first of all we have
added some elements inside a vector then
we have used V Dot size function then we
dot capacity function then Max size
function after that we have resized the
vector and then check it for the size of
it after that we use V Dot empty
function
so now let's try to run this code
okay I think we have done something
wrong
we haven't put the brackets over here
okay now let's try again
here it is
Vector size is 10
because we have put 1 to 10 then
capacity of vector is 16 okay then Max
size of vector is this
then Vector size after resizing because
we have done we have wrote the number 5
as we can see so that is why Vector size
after resizing is 5.
and Vector is not empty as we know
because inside the vector there are five
elements so it is not empty which is
true
so
these were some examples of vectors in C
plus plus
moving on
STL stands for standard template Library
it is a set of template classes that
provide us data structures and
algorithms or containers it allows the
programmer to use predefined functions
which helps them to write the code
quickly and in an efficient way
for example you are solving a problem
that's needs sorting now instead of
writing the code to sort you can make
use of STL
now STL mainly consists of four
components that is containers iterators
algorithms and function objects so first
is containers
these are collection of objects that
store data of similar type in STL we
have different types of containers some
of them are array Vector set map and
these containers are generic in nature
so further these containers are of three
types that is sequence container
associative container and container
adapters
sequence containers these are those
containers that can be accessed
sequentially for example Vector DQ list
are some of the containers that store
data in a linear form
next is associative container these are
those containers that Implement sorted
data structures in this elements are
retrieved via keys and each associative
container maintain its keys in sorted
order
example set multiset map and multi-map
after that container adapters these
containers are like sequential
containers but they are implemented by
modifying their interface to provide the
desired behavior for example stack queue
and priority queue are some examples of
container adapters
now coming to iterators in STL iterator
plays an important role as it links
algorithms and containers iterators are
those entities that helps in traversing
through containers they are used to
point at the memory address of the steel
containers
iterators also helps in traversal from
one element to the next element in the
range using operators like increment
operator
iterator contains two functions that is
begin function and N function the begin
function Returns the iterator to the
first element and the end function
Returns the iterator to the last element
now coming to algorithms
algorithms in STL can be defined as
procedure that are applied to the
containers and provide some operations
on the content of the container and
because STL algorithms are built in so
that is why they save considerable
amount of time
in algorithms we just have to make a
function call and we don't have to write
the lines of code to implement it
now let's have a look at types of
algorithms
first is modifying algorithm non
modifying algorithm sorting algorithm
searching algorithm and numeric
algorithm
modifying algorithms are those
algorithms that make changes to the
sequences
Swap and reverse functions are some
examples of it
then non-modifying algorithm
non-modifying algorithm are basically
read-only function they do not modify
the data on which they work on some
examples are count equal and search
functions
then sorting algorithms this algorithm
is used to sort the container elements
its example is sort function
next is searching algorithm as the name
suggests this algorithm searches for the
element binary search algorithm is
mostly use search algorithm
last is numeric algorithm this algorithm
work on numeric values or we can say it
solves some numeric problems examples
are accumulate function and partial sum
functions
now coming to function objects
function objects are also known as
functors a function object is an object
of template class that implements call
operator
this call Operator allows the object to
be used with same syntax as regular
function call
for example suppose you have declared an
object obj of a class in which operator
is defined
then you can use the object obj just
like a normal function
function objects also helps in
generating the data and it also helps in
testing purposes
now in order to do some examples let's
move to our code editor that is vs code
so here we will do an example of vector
container so let's make a new file
and let's name it STL dot CPP
now we'll add the header files
now writing namespace standard
now we will add before namespace
standard we have to add the header file
for vectors
because we are doing the example of
vector so that is why we have to add the
header file or vector
okay now
we'll write int Main
now first of all we'll declare the
vector so we'll write vector
end within the angle brackets now we
will write
the name of the vector that is V
okay now we have to push
some elements inside the vector for that
we have to use for Loop so we'll write
for keyword
I equals
let's say 1
I less than
equals 10
I plus plus that is increment operator
okay now we have to push the elements
one by one so we'll write V Dot
push back
and inside the bracket we will put I
so the elements will keep on adding one
by one at the end of the vector
so now we will check the size of the
vector so we'll write
we'll write the message size
and then the function B dot size
it will tell us the size of the vector
that is the number of elements inside it
as we can see they that we have put 10
elements inside the vector one by one so
it must be 10.
so in order to check it we have used
this function V Dot size
okay now we'll use another function
that is V Dot resize
it will resize the size of the vector
so whatever we put inside this bracket
like let's say I've put 7 so its size
now would be 7.
and we need to check this also
so we'll again use the function
size so first of all we'll display the
message
after
resizing
it becomes
V Dot size
it will print the size of the vector
after resizing okay
no
we use another function V Dot empty for
that we have to use if condition
so we'll write
V Dot empty
brackets
we know that if V Dot empty equals true
then it means it is empty and if it
equals false then it means it is not
empty so we'll simply display the
message that it is not empty
all right C out
and now we'll write with Slash n
not empty
before go to
write the
commas over here okay
now in else
we will write
it is empty
we can also do this the other way around
like we can put V Dot empty equals to
true and then inside that bracket we can
write it is empty but it's your choice
okay now
we'll display the elements of the vector
for that we have to first
write the message so we'll write
elements of vector
then after this using for Loop and
iterator we will print those elements
so let's do this we'll write for
and inside for Loop we'll write
Auto
ID here the auto keyword specifies the
type of variable that is being declared
will be automatically deducted from the
initializer and I T is the iterator
now we'll write i t equals V Dot begin
and we know that we dot begin function
will point to the first element of the
vector
so
after that we'll write
it
not equal to V Dot end
and it will point to the last element of
the vector
now we'll write i t plus plus
now
will print the iterator using the
reference operator
and in order to make some space we'll
write this
now we return 0.
okay now
let's try to run this
okay
here is the problem I think
now let's try one another time
here it is size 10
after that after resizing it becomes
seven
firstly we add the elements by pushing
one by one using the pushback function
10 elements were added so size is 10
after that we have resized it so after
resizing it becomes seven
and then we have used the function empty
so it was not empty so that is why the
message display is not empty then the
elements of vector the forgot to put
space over here in elements of vector
one two three four five six seven
and that is correct
okay
now we'll do one example of iterator
in this example we'll simply
print the elements of a vector using
iterator
so first of all let's name this
stl2.cpp
now we'll write the header files
hash include iostream
in this we'll add three header files now
we'll write
hash include
iterator
because we have to use iterator so that
is why we are doing this
and we also have to use the vector so
we'll write hash include
vector
now we'll write namespace standard
now we'll start with int Main
so first of all we'll declare a vector
in which there are some elements as in
previous question we already learned how
to add elements in a vector so in this
question we'll simply declare those
elements inside a vector so we'll write
vector
in inside the angle brackets
now let's say ER is the name of this
vector
now we'll write the
elements
five five elements are there
now we have to declare iterator to a
vector
so this is how we'll do it we'll write
then
the data type inside the angle brackets
then after this we'll write the scope
resolution operator
like this now iterator
keyword
then the name of the iterator that is
PTR
now we'll display the vector elements
using for Loop and using the functions
begin and end
so we'll write
first of all we have to display a
message
okay we will write
the elements
of vector
r
okay
now semicolon
Now using for Loop
will write
the PTR that is the iterator
AR
dot begin
as we know that AR is the name of the
vector
AR dot begin begin function will point
to the first element of the vector
then
PTR
less than a r dot
end
we know end function
and function will point to the last
element of the vector
okay now we'll write
AR plus plus
sorry PTR plus plus
now we have to display it and
will display it using the reference
operator and the name of iterator that
is PTR
we'll make some space
now at last we'll write return 0.
now let's try to run this
the elements of vector r as you can see
the elements of vector are one two three
four five
so this is how you can print the
elements of a vector using the iterator
here is the vector and with the help of
iterator we have printed these elements
one two three four five
now we'll do one simple example of
algorithm
first of all let's name this
tl3.cpp
now in this example we'll use swap
algorithm to swap two integers
and we know that swap is a template
function so let's do this first of all
we'll write
hash include iostream
Now using namespace standard
we'll start with int Main
now first of all we declare a variable
let's say seven
and
second variable
let's say 10.
first of all we'll display the value of
these variables that
before swapping and after swapping so
that is where
we'll write
value of I
now here we'll write
value of J
handle
okay now we'll use the swap algorithm
and here we'll mention the elements we
want to swap I comma J
it will simply swap the contents of
these two elements
now we'll write
after swapping
handle
will do same for J
this is a very basic example but we have
to see the functionality of it
we'll write
parallel okay
now we'll write return 0.
now we'll run this
yeah value of I 7 value of J is 10 after
swapping I 10 j7
it will look
better if we have root like this
let's make it look good
yeah value 5 7 value of J is 10 after
swapping I becomes 10 and J becomes 7.
so this is how we can swap the elements
using swap algorithm there are some more
algorithms you can write those as well
and now at last we'll do one example of
function object
let's name this as stl4.cpp
all right now
we'll add the header file
hash include iostream
now we'll write namespace standard
now in this question first of all we'll
start with the function so first of all
we'll make a class
function
obj
now we'll write access specifier public
int
here we will write the call operator
as we know the syntax
operator
bracket
then
another bracket for the arguments
and X
comma and
y
so this is the syntax of it and now
whatever we want to do with these two
variables let's say we want to multiply
so we'll write return X
into y
all right
as this is a class so we have to write
the semicolon
now we'll write int Main
okay now we'll write infin after int
Main
here we will write the name of the class
because
we have to define the object of it now
the object is f o
so here class name is function obj and
its object is fo and as I have explained
earlier here I can use F4 object like a
normal function because f o is the
object of class function obj in which
call Operator is defined so it will act
like a normal function
so now
we'll make a variable let's say multiply
so we'll write mult equals F4
and because it acts like a normal
function so we'll pass the parameters
4 and 7.
now in order to display we'll write C
out and
we'll write
multiplication
of X and Y
is
now we'll write the name of the variable
mult
because the result is getting stored in
multi-variable now we'll write return 0.
[Applause]
now let's try to run this
here we can see multiplication of X and
Y is 28
and that is true 4 into 7 equals 28
so it is working and this is the example
of functor or function object let's go
ahead and have a look at why enums are
used in C plus plus
enums are short for enumerations
these are basically used when we have
some set of possible values and we have
to select one out of it for example
suppose you are the shop owner and you
have four types of coffee in your coffee
machine that is cold coffee hot coffee
black coffee and mocha and you don't
want the trouble of customer putting any
other coffee name in The Machine
which is not there
then in situations like these
enumerations are used
because in enumerations we have to
choose from predefined values and it is
also helpful for documentation and
readability purpose
now let's understand what is enumeration
enum or enumeration is a user defined
data type in which a set of values are
specified for the variable and the
variable can take out any value from the
set of values and it is also a way to
use integers to represent values we can
assign values to enum but if we do not
assign any value then the compiler
assigns value to them starting from 0.
coming to its syntax
which is enum that is the keyword for
enumerated type then enumerator type
name is written then under brackets
possible values of type enum are written
for example here enumeration name is
player and values are Ronaldo's Messi
Neymar which are the names of players
in this example by default Ronaldo is
zero salaha is one messy is to Neymar is
three because we know by default
compiler assigns them value which start
from 0 and so on
but we can change these default values
by assigning values to them like here
Ronaldo's value is now 4 salaha's value
is to Messi's value is 8 Neymar's value
is 1.
now let's have a look at an example in
which we will print the default value of
months
so in this example we have enum name as
months and enumerated values as January
February March and so on
and in order to access these values we
have written enumeration name and after
that the variable
as we can see inside mean function m is
the variable and its type is months now
here we have assigned the month March to
the variable n and then we are printing
the variable M plus 1. here plus 1 will
print the value next to the month March
that is 3 and similarly if we write plus
2 then it will print then one next to it
that is 4. these values are default
integer values
after printing the output value is 3.
because we have printed M plus 1 where m
is 2 and plus 1 makes it 3.
now let's understand how to use enum
with flags
in this example we will choose a mobile
having any of the two features among
three
here the name of enumeration is mobile
and its enumerated values are battery
capacity camera quality large storage
and we have assigned values to them 1 2
and 4 respectively and because we are
doing this example of enums with flags
that is why we are using integer values
of power 2 because it avoids the
overlapping
inside the main function we are using
bitwise or operator because we want to
choose the mobile having both camera
quality and large storage capacity and
we know that bitwise operator adds the
binary of two integers
so the value of camera quality is 2 and
value of large storage is 4.
when we use a bitwise or operator in
between these two features so it will
add up their binary giving the decimal
number as 6.
so the output 6 is showing both the
camera quality and large storage are
used
now let's do some examples of
Illumination in our code editor that is
vs code
okay now let's make a new file
and name the file as
enum.cpv
in this example the enumeration name
will be Captain and the enumerated
values will be the team members out of
which we will select one member as
Captain and with if condition we will
verify if he is the selected captain or
not
it will be a basic example so first of
all let's write hash include iostream
now we'll add the namespace standard
okay now we'll write enumeration enum
Captain which is the name of the
enumeration type
and now we will write the enumerated
values
which is let's say
a b
said
Robbie
Sami
and Jake
these are the team members
now we'll write int Main
[Music]
now here we will first of all write
Captain which is the name of the
numerator type
then we'll make the variable out of it
cap
and let's say Avi is the captain so
we'll write a v
now here we will write if condition
we'll write if
cap equal to a v
then we'll display
our captain is away and its value is
whatever the value this Avis value here
is 0 so we'll display that
so we'll write
our captain
is a v
and its value
is
then we'll write a v
as we know that a v is at First Position
then its value would be default value
would be zero
Okay so
here we will write endl
now in else
here if we put Sid rho B Sami Jake as
Captain or we if we declare them as
Captain then this message would be
declared which we will be writing in
else
so the message would be
he is not our captain
then over here we will write return 0.
okay now let's try to run this
another button
um
our captain is away and its value is
zero
because here Captain we have declared a
v so that is why this is
printing if we write let's say Sami over
here
then it will print the else part
he is not our captain and if we write
Jake or said
then also it will print the same
he's not a captain only in case of Avi
it will print our captain is away and
its value is
a V's value
so this was the basic example of
enumeration now let's move on to one
another example now
let's make a new file
and name it as enum2
dot CPP
okay
now we will add the header files hash
include irstream
and using namespace standard
so here we will do an example in which
enumeration name will be supercars and
to the values we will assign some
integers to them which will be the speed
of those cars and then we will compare
them using comparison operator in terms
of speed
so
we will write enum
the name of enumeration that is let's
say supercars
okay
now inside the bracket
we'll write the name of the cars which
are the values
and we will assign
some integers
these integers are actually speed of
these cars
then
Valkyrie
speed is 240.
now
Roadster
250.
okay now as we have created the enum now
we will start within Main
so we will write the numerator type name
supercars
now the variable speed
1 because we want to create two
variables in order to compare them so
first we will create speed one
now again
speed 2.
now we will assign the two cars that we
want to compare to these variables
so speed 1 will be
Valkyrie
and Speed 2 would be
Roadster
okay now we will write the if condition
and inside the if condition we will
compare the speed of these two cars
so we will write speed one
if speed 1 is less than
speed 2.
okay
then we will print
that it's a win for Roadster because
Speed 2 is Road certain speed 1 is
Valkyrie so we'll write it's a win for
Roadster
with the speed we'll also write the
speed with the speed
of
this P2 will display the speed of
Roadster that is 250.
okay now else condition
so here we will write
it's a win for valkyrie
with the speed
of
here we'll write speed one
okay
now we have to write int main but before
that we will write the brackets which we
forgot to mention
returns zero
okay I think it's done now let's try to
run this
here we can see it's a Win 4 Roadster
with the speed of 250. as we know that
the speed of Roadster here is 250 and
the valkyrie speed is 240 so when we
compare it Speed 2 that is Roadster
winds because Roadster is 250.
so this was the second example now let's
do one last example
let's name this
okay
enum3 dot CPP
we'll write hash include IO stream
now namespace standard
now in this example we will see how to
use switch statement with the
enumeration
Okay so
first of all
inside int Main
we will write
enum
color is the name of the numeration type
then we'll write the values
red
blue
green
and yellow
these are the values
now here we will use switch statement
but before doing that we have to assign
one color to a variable so first of all
we have to create that variable and in
order to create the variable we will
write the numeration type name color
and then
the variable name select
now we will assign
one color from the above colors
let's say yellow
now in switch statement we will write
first of all we'll write switch
statement
switch and
we will pass here the variable that is
Select
basically we are passing yellow
because yellow is assigned to the
variable select and that is why it is
getting passed
so now case 1 that is case red
first of all we'll write the case red
with a colon in the end now we will
print that it is red
now we'll write the break statement
break statement basically ends the case
or terminates the case
so after that
the second case that is case blue
colon
now here we will print
it is blue
and similarly
break statement
we'll do same for all of these colors
green and yellow also
and switch statement will help us to
find which color is passed and will
display the message of that color
so here we will write green
it is green
break statement
now case yellow
now we'll write it is yellow
now he will write break
okay now at last we have to write return
now as we know that we have we have
passed a particular color
to the variable select and select
is the expression and switch statement
will help us
in comparing the variable select value
to the value of different blocks and one
which matches that particular block will
execute
okay now let's try to run this one
here we can see
it is yellow is being printed
which is the right answer because we
have passed the color yellow to the
select that is why only the case yellow
output is being printed
so
this is how you can use switch statement
with the numeration in this session we
are going to learn about C plus plus GUI
that is graphical user interface and how
to configure visual studio and make a
GUI application to develop C plus plus
GUI or C plus plus graphical user
interface apps we must have an IDE that
supports C plus plus GUI applications
and visual studio is one of the best IDE
for that here IDE stands for integrated
development environment there are many
versions of visual studio for GUI apps
but I suggest you to download visual
studio 2019
there are three editions of Visual
Studio 2019 that is community
professional and Enterprise
we can download the Community Edition
once the visual studio is downloaded and
installed then you need to launch this
application after that you can select
the color theme
and change the development settings to
visual C plus
then the visual studio will look like
this
then here we will click on this create a
new project
and now we have to search for a project
template named CLR
mtproject.net framework
so we'll type CLR
empty project.net framework here it is
make sure that there is dotnet framework
over here
now all we have to do is to click on
this
and select next
now here we can name our project let's
say I have named IT project 2 and we can
select the location
and now we can click on this create
button
now our project is being created
so here it is
so now let's create a form file by going
to the project
then add item
add new item
now here visual C plus plus under visual
C plus plus we'll click on UI and then
Windows Form we'll click on this Windows
Form and
click on this add button
so our file is loading
so it will show you this error but you
don't need to worry about this one you
can simply close it
now we will go to Project
then into properties
then now we'll click on this Linker
open this Linker
now I will go to the system
then inside this subsystem
over here
will select windows
here it is
now after doing this then we go to
Advanced
and in advance we can change this
entry point to Main
we'll write miin Main
this main is the starting function
now we can press OK over here
now you need to open this myform.cpb
here it is and you have to copy this
code
and just paste it over here
we will add this code in the description
you can take this code from there and
add it
now make sure to write your project name
over here
like my project name is Project 2 so
I'll write
project
2.
yes
so after doing this we can save it by
pressing Ctrl and S
and now we can go to myform.h
here we can see there is no form so we
need to save it and close this
Visual Studio once
now we need to open the visual studio
again
we'll go over here we'll write Visual
Studio 2019 here it is we'll click on
this
and this is launching
we can click on this project too
now let's go to
myform.h
we'll click on this
it is getting loaded
here we can see the form earlier we are
only able to see the code but now we can
see this form
now we can check this by running it by
clicking on this local Windows debugger
button we'll click on that
and let's see if it is running or not
it will take some time
so here it is it is running properly as
you can see this is my form
and this is ready to use so it is the
debugging is going on so if we have to
close the debugging or stop the
debugging we can click on this cross
button
so the debugging is closed now and we
have verified that the form is running
correctly
we can also add some buttons and labels
to this form like this we can click on
this toolbox then we can select this
button
and we can click this over here
so this is our button and we can select
some more labels
all right we can click on this toolbox
again
and select another button
like this over here
and
now we can select a label let's say
and click over here
and we can also adjust the size of these
buttons
like this
and like this we can adjust the size and
this is the label
we have to adjust his size by setting
its format we can do it by clicking on
this label and going to properties
over here we can see as you have clicked
on the label
so we can see the text that is label one
here we can see text
label one so it is this text which is
written we can change this one
by clicking on this we can select
hello there we can write it like this
and
it will be shown over this side
now we must click
the label first then only we can access
the button or label
so now let's say this is the font so we
can click on this font and adjust this
here it is let's say
I have adjusted it to 18 size and made
it bold now we can click this okay over
this side so here we can see hello there
it is bold now similarly we can do this
for button as well as we have clicked on
this button as you can see now I can go
to this properties
now inside this properties there is text
that is button one we can see we can
change this like we can write click here
and we can also adjust its font
here it is
let's say 12.
and bold oblique you click on this okay
and here it is
click here
we can adjust it over there and suppose
if you want to delete some button or
label or something like that so we can
click on this and
right click on this side and here we can
see delete we'll click on this delete
and it will be deleted
there are more options in toolbox like
there is text box
list box list View
picture box check Box Etc we can select
as per our choice and we can adjust its
layout or editing by going to the
properties column
so now let's make a calculator program
so for that we have to create a
calculator layout so let's just delete
all these
delete this one
and we'll delete this one as well
now we'll go to the toolbox
and select a text box we can search it
over here
text box
here it is you can click on that
and put it over here
here it is
we have to adjust its formatting
so we'll go to properties and we'll go
to font
and click on this font
now let's say adjust it to
22. and
make it bold
oblique yes now I'll click on this okay
and
we have to create another one so
instead of doing this all we can copy
this one and to copy this we can go to
this side and click right click over
here
and we can click on this copy
and then we can paste it
here it is because you have to enter two
numbers and for that we need to have two
text boxes for a calculator
all right now in between we can mention
the operation or operator whatsoever for
that we can we have to select the label
and we'll go to toolbox
and
here it is
text box
but we have to select label
all right
label
we click on this label and
put it over here
now we have to adjust it
now here we will write let's say it's
font would be 20 and
it would be bold oblique
it will look nice then click on OK
now we have to adjust what is written
inside it so we can go to text and click
on this
label one now
we can write operator
but it would be so long so we can write
op that means operator
all right
it gives the idea
about the operator
we have to adjust it a bit
all right here it is and
okay now we have to create a buttons for
addition subtraction multiplication so
we'll go to toolbox
and now we'll
search for buttons
we'll click on button and put it over
here
and now we'll adjust it by going to
properties
and going to fonts
let's adjust it to
22 and make it bold
now we'll click on OK
and now we have to change the label of
it first of all let's select
it's layout like this
it would be big
now we'll go to properties
and we'll go to text
and
we'll make an addition sign over here
and now I'll click on this so here we
can see so now we'll copy this button to
create the next three buttons so
click on this copy and paste it
we'll do this for the other two as well
and we'll change the text by going to
properties later onwards
here it is
so first will be addition then here
let's make it subtraction we're going to
properties we'll click on this
properties
now
let's make this text as
minus
all right now we can also change the
color of this text
let's say
we can make this
this here it is blue in color now we'll
change this one we'll go to properties
and make this as
sign of multiplication but we'll press X
so that will look nice
all right now this one will go to
properties and change this to
division sign
and we can change this one as well
it will look nice let's make it this
similar color to the subtraction
all right here it is here are four
buttons addition subtraction
multiplication and division
now we have to display the result as
well so we'll go to toolbox
and we'll search for label
we'll click on this label
and put it over here
all right
let's make it like this and let's put it
or this side it will look nice over here
property is now we have to adjust it
let's make it 22 bold oblique
okay
here is our result and let's name it as
result as well we'll go to text here it
is labeled to return
we'll write result
now whatsoever operation is done its
result or output is displayed over this
side now all we need to do is to add the
functionality to these buttons
so let's do that we'll click on this
two times
on this button and the button name
actual name of that button is button one
so here it is
so this part is for button one and we
know that button one is addition so we
need to do addition over here
so let's start
first of all we'll
have to declare a variable
hint result or output or answer
whatsoever we want let's write output
now to add those we need the names of
those two text boxes so we'll go to
format design
and we need these names both of these
text box names so we'll click on this
first and we'll go to properties so here
it is text box one we can see and we
click on this
and properties this is text box two
and this is similarly this is button one
button two button three button 4. we can
check this by going to properties and by
clicking them and going to properties so
this is text box one and this is text
box two
so now we know the names
now all we have to do
is to write
text box
text box where B is capital
we have to write the exact name we can
check it over here that this is text box
we can check the spelling this is text
box two this is label one this is button
one this is button two we can
check the spellings from there now
now we have to use the
Arrow operator
we'll write like this this is the air
operator this will give us the access to
the members of the object
all right so
we have to change the text so we'll
write text
T capital
all right now we have to add
the text box too
and we'll do it same
we'll write this our operator
and text
now this addition which we have written
over here is ROM
because we are actually adding the
strings
as you can see
when we type any number over here it is
a string and same goes for this part
so we have to convert it
first we will convert both of these text
to integer and then we will
again convert the result into string
because we have to display it over here
and for that we need a string so then
again we have to convert it to the
string and let's do it
so what we gonna do is we'll write
system
and then this scope resolution operator
convert
again scope resolution inverter
operator sorry to
end
16.
I must be Capital keep in mind to end
all right now here we'll write
text
box with B capital
and then this error operator
and we'll write text
all right
after that sign of addition
again we'll do the same System Scope
resolution operator
convert scope resolution operator
to
end
and
text box 2 here we have to write text
box too
Arrow operator
text
all right
here is the addition part now we have to
display the result
now to that first check the name of the
result like this is the result we'll
click on this and go to properties
its name is label 2.
so we have to make the changes into
label 2. we'll go to this
for match
now we'll
have to change the text that is we have
to change the result that is written
into the output
so for that we will write Label 2 which
is the name
then this Arrow operator
after that we'll write text because we
have to change it
and then
we'll write system
scope resolution operator
convert
to
string because we have to display the
output into string
as I have already told you
all right
now
over here we have to write output
this output
okay
so let's check if it is working or not
we'll go to local Windows debugger and
click on this
hope it works
here it is
my form
so let's try to add let's say five
plus nine
and we'll click on this add button
14 and we know that 5 plus 9 equal to 14
so
it is working fine we can see and now we
have to do this for all the buttons that
is subtraction multiplication and
division so let's go ahead and do that
let's first close this debugging
you have stopped the debugging and we'll
go to this
now we have to do that for
the next three buttons will
all right
now we'll click on this
subtraction button two times
here we can see
now the code is same for all of these
and
so we can copy the code from here
and we have just copied it and we'll
paste it and will make the changes in
the sign like I have used here minus
sign for the subtraction
and the rest is good yeah
all right now we'll do it for the next
one that is
multiplication
I'll double click on that and here it is
we'll copy the code from here
and paste it
will change the sign
the subtraction note the multiplication
sign this is this multiplication sign
and now
the next one that is division
here we go
we'll again select
copy
and paste
let's change the sign of this as well
okay
as we have done the changes so let's
save it by pressing Ctrl and S
and
it is saved now let's try to run this
hope it works we'll click on this local
Windows debugger
it usually takes some time and here it
is
so let's try now five
Plus
six let's do this first of all Edition
11 now
will do
20 minus 6 so we'll click on this minus
and 20 minus 6 equals to 14 that's right
and now we'll do 20 into
3 that is 60
we click on this multiply sign 20 into 3
that is 60 it is right
now let's say
15 and
3 yeah
we click on divide and this is five so
all of our buttons is working fine so
this is how we can create a calculator
in Visual Studio 2019
you can also create this calculated
program in your PC all you need to do is
to download visual studio 2019 and
install it and you can follow the steps
and you can create this calculator
application in this video I present you
some commonly asked C plus plus
interview questions these questions will
help you in your preparation and serve
you as a valuable resource while
preparing for the interviews
in this video we will cover some
conceptual questions multiple choice
questions output based questions and
some programming questions of C plus
plus
so without further Ado let's get started
starting with the first question that is
what is the difference between C and C
plus plus
now C language is a procedure oriented
language whereas C plus plus is
partially object oriented language
because it doesn't support object
oriented features completely
C language supports top-down approach
and C plus plus supports a bottom-up
approach here the bottom-up approach
means the development of modules in C
plus starts from the bottom
C doesn't support function or operator
overloading whereas C plus plus supports
both function and operator overloading
C language doesn't support virtual
endpoint function C plus plus language
supports both virtual and friend
function
C language has 32 keywords whereas C
plus plus has 52 keywords
next question is what are classes and
objects in C plus plus
a class is a user defined data type that
contains data members and member
functions it is defined with keyword
class
objects are defined as an instance of a
once the object is created then it can
operate on both data members and member
functions
coming to the third question that is
what are access modifiers
access modifiers are used to define
accessibility for the class members
it defines how the members of the class
are accessed outside the class scope
there are three types of access
modifiers that is private public and
protected
let's start with private
the members who are declared as private
cannot be accessed directly from outside
the class
they can only be accessed by the member
functions inside the class
now public the members who are declared
as public can be accessed from within
the class as well as outside the class
and even from outside the package as
well
now protected the members who are
declared as protected can be accessed
from within the class and from the
derived class
now coming to the next question that is
what is C plus plus oops concept
oops stands for object oriented
programming
there are some concepts of oops that is
object class inheritance polymorphism
encapsulation and abstraction
now let's understand these Concepts
let's start with object an object is a
basic unit of object oriented
programming it can be defined as an
instance of a class
we can create multiple objects of a
class
now class is a template of an object
it is user defined which holds member
functions and data members
the data and code which is defined
inside the class are said to be the
members of the class
now inheritance inheritance can be
defined as a process in which child
class inherits all the properties and
behavior of its parent class
the class which is inherited is called
the base class and the class which
inherits is called the derived class
now polymorphism
polymorphism is the ability to give
different meanings to the same function
it allows us to redefine a function and
create it with a completely new
definition
now encapsulation encapsulation means
binding code and data together into a
single unit
no abstraction that abstraction
specifies hiding the internal details
for the Simplicity and showing the
functionality to the user
now coming to the next question that is
what is the difference between a while
loop and a do while loop
so first is while loop
while loop verifies the condition
if it's true then it iterates the loop
till the condition becomes false
on the other side do while loop first
iterates the loop body once then it
checks for the condition
in while loop the syntax is while
keyword
then condition inside the brackets
the syntax of do while loop is do block
and after that while keyword with a
condition
in the while loop if the condition is
false then not a single statement will
execute inside the loop
on the other hand in do while loop if
the condition is false then also the
body will execute once
now
coming to the sixth question that is
what is a Constructor
a Constructor can be defined as a member
function that is invoked whenever we
create an object
it has the same name as that of class
there are two types of Constructors in C
plus plus
that is default Constructor and
parameterized Constructor
default Constructor are those
Constructor which do not take any
parameters if we don't Define any
Constructor then the compiler will
automatically provide a default
Constructor
on the other hand parameterized
Constructor are those Constructors in
which we can pass the arguments
now coming to the next question
which of the following operator cannot
be overloaded
our options are a subtraction operator B
addition operator C ternary operator and
D module operator
so our correct answer is
C ternary operator because overloading
this operator is not synthetically
possible
so let's move on to our next question
write a program to find the factorial of
a number
so here we have to write a program of
factorial in which we will enter a
number and its factorial is displayed on
the screen
so here we have declared an integer n
which we will take an input from the
user and another variable fact which we
have initialized as one
after that we have displayed a message
enter a positive integer
and we have taken an input of the
integer
now if the number or integer entered by
user is less than 0 that is in the
negative then it will display error as
there is no factorial of negative number
and all the positive number will go to
the else block
inside the else block we have used for
Loop and it is iterating from 1 to n
that is the number users had entered
and inside the for Loop it is written
fact into equal to I which can also be
written as fact equal to fact into I
which means one by one all the numbers
from 1 to n will be multiplied by fact
variable and the result will be stored
in the fact variable itself
once the iteration is done then the fact
variable where the result is stored is
displayed
so this is the factorial program
now coming to the ninth question that is
what is operator overloading
operator overloading is a mechanism in
which we provide an additional meaning
to The Operators
in this an operator is overloaded to
give user defined meaning
for example we can overload an addition
operator in a class like string to
concatenate two strings by only using
addition sign
now a next question is
what if we compile a program without the
main function now another question
arises is it possible to compile a
program without the main function
so the answer is yes we can compile a
program without the main function but we
cannot run or execute the program
because the main function is the entry
point from where all the execution
begins and without the entry point the
program is not executable
so we can compile the program but we
cannot run it without the main function
now moving to the next question
what is operator overloading and
function overloading
as we have already discussed Operator
overloading Operator overloading allows
operators to have an extended meaning
apart from their predefined meaning
function overloading on the other hand
defines a method in such a way that
there are multiple ways to call them
now our next question is what is the
difference between equal to operator and
assignment operator
the equal to operator checks whether two
values are equal or not
if equal then it's true otherwise it
will return false
the assignment operator on the other
hand assigns the value of write variable
to the left variable
coming to the 13th question
that is when void return type is used
void return type is used when we don't
want to return any value
it specifies that the function doesn't
return a value
function with void return type completes
its task and then Returns the control to
the caller
so next question is what is call by
value and call by reference in C plus
plus
of all both of these methods that is
called by value and call by reference
are the methods to pass the values to
the functions
so let's start with the first method
that is call by Value method
in call by Value method we pass the
copies of actual parameters to the
function's formal parameters this means
if there is any change in the values
inside the function then that change
will not affect the actual values
in call by reference method the
reference or address of actual
parameters is sent to the function's
formal parameters this means any change
in the values inside the function will
be reflected in the actual values
because here we are sending the address
of the values
coming to the 15th question that is what
is inline function
the inline function is expanded in line
when it's called
when this function is called the whole
code of inline function gets inserted or
substituted at the inline function call
or in other words the compiler replaces
the function calling location with the
definition of the inline function at
compile time
its syntax is the inline keyword return
type and function name
and parameters inside the brackets
coming to the next question that is what
are Pointers in C plus plus
pointers are the variables that holds
the memory address of another variable
the type of variable must correspond
with the type of pointer for example the
pointer of corrected type can hold the
address of character type variable and
the same goes for integer and other data
types
its syntax is type of variable and s26
sign with the name of pointer
moving to the next question that is what
is scope resolution operator
a scope resolution operator is
represented as shown
this operator is used to associate
function definition to a particular
class
this operator is used for the following
purposes to access a global variable
when we have a local variable with same
name
second is to define a function outside
the class
now moving to the next question
and this question is output based
question
so the question is what is the output of
the following C plus plus program
so in this question we have to determine
the output of the following program and
we have to select the correct answer
from the following options
so in this program as we can see two
variables I and X are initialized as 0.
and after that do block is there and we
know the do block executes for once
regardless of any condition
and inside the do block there is if
statement in which the condition is if I
mode equal to 0 then only the block will
execute
so if I is initially 0 and we know 0
mode 5 is 0 so the condition is
satisfied and it will display 0 as the
value of x
x is 0 initially after that the value is
incremented for both I and X now the
value of I is 1 and 1 mode 5 is 1 so it
doesn't satisfy the condition
so the value of I will increment again
and similarly the process will repeat
for 2 mod 5 3 mode 5 4 mode 5 but 5 mode
5 is 0 so the value of x here which is 1
now will be displayed and increments to
2.
then afterwards I becomes 6 then 7 then
8 then 9 on incrementing but doesn't
meet the condition at that time
but when it becomes 10 the control will
move outside the loop and 2 will be
displayed so our answer becomes 0 1 and
2.
so this is our answer 0 1 2.
now let's move on to the next question
so this question is a multiple choice
question and in this question we have to
determine the size of integer data type
so our options are four bytes one byte 8
bytes and two bytes
so our answer is 4 bytes
four bytes is the size of integer data
type
so now let's move to the next question
this question is what is STD in C plus
plus
first option is STD is standard class in
C plus plus SCD is standard file reading
header in C plus plus STD is a standard
header file then last option is STD is
standard namespace in C plus plus
so our correct answer is
STD is a standard namespace in C plus
plus
it is used in programs while writing
using namespace standards and it tells
the compiler to take everything in
standard namespace
so let's move on to the next question
so in this question we have to tell how
to input a string in C plus plus with
spaces
now we all know how to input a string in
C plus plus without spaces because it's
quite easy but let's understand how to
do it with spaces
so in this question as you can see there
is a string that we have declared s the
name of the string is s after that we
have displayed a message enter the
sentence with spaces and then we are
taking the input here get line is the
member function of istream class which
is used to read the string with spaces
so as we can see get line after that in
the bracket C in which is used to take
the input after that the name of the
string that is s
and after that we have displayed the
string name that is s
so this is how we can take the input
from the user with spaces using this get
line function
so let's move to our next question
that is what is the difference between
new and malloc
now both of these are used to allocate
memory
so let's start with new
new is an operator whereas malloc is a
function
the new operator calls the Constructor
on the other hand malloc function
doesn't call The Constructor
in case of new there is no need to
specify memory size while using new
operator
in case of malloc we have to specify the
memory size in malloc function
new operator can be overloaded whereas
malloc function can never be overloaded
now next question is what is the
difference between prefix and postfix
in prefix
first the value is incremented and then
the value is assigned to the expression
but in case of postfix the value is
assigned to the expression and then the
variable's value is incremented
now coming to the next question
that is what is the output of the below
C plus plus program
so as we can see the program
this is the program of enumeration as we
can see the enum keyword
so here three enum variables are there
that is blue green and great
and we know that there are some default
values that are assigned to the enum
variables that starts from 0.
but we also know that we can change
these default values so as you can see
in this question green equals five so
greens value is 5. and we can see the
element great has no value so in enum if
this case arises then the value of the
next element would be 1 greater than its
previous element so ultimately the value
of great element would be 6.
so as you can see here we have printed
blue and grid
so our output would be 0 and 6.
that means the value of blue is 0 and
the value of great is 6.
so now let's move on to the next
question
in this question we have to find the
frequency of a number in C plus plus
so as you can see in the program we have
given this number one three three two
four two two five two three and we have
to find the frequency of the number 2
that is k equals to 2 K is the number
so in this program first of all we'll
pass both of these values to a function
named frequency
now inside that function we have
declared a counter variable C and
initialized it with 0. now after that we
have used while loop and inside the
while loop we have put the condition num
greater than 0.
now it means the loop will execute till
the value of num is greater than 0. now
after that inside the while loop we have
put an if statement condition that is
num mod 10 equals K now keep in mind
that K is the number which we want to
find the frequency of that is 2.
now num mode 10 we know that any number
when mode with 10 gives the last digit
of that number
so one by one all the digits of this num
variable will be checked
starting from 3 then 2 then 5 then 2
then again 2 then 4 similarly goes on
so one by one all of these digits
will be checked with the value of K that
is 2 and if the digit matches with k
then that counter variable which we have
initialized as 0 will increment
and after that num equals to num divided
by 10 will delete that last element so
that the repetition of digits don't
occur
so this is how we can find the frequency
of a number in C plus plus so now let's
move on to the next question
which of the following statement is
correct about the program given below
this is again an output based question
so let's have a look at the program
and these are its options 7 14 0 and 1.
so we have to select one out of it
so in this program we can see a variable
X is declared and a pointer p is there
and we have assigned this value 7 to the
variable X
after that we are storing the memory
location of x to this pointer p
and at last we are displaying the output
using the D reference operator as we
know that if we want to display the
value at an address then we use D
reference operator
so our output would be 7 as the
value at that memory location is 7. now
let's move on to the next question
which of the following statement is
correct about the program given below
now in this question again we have to
determine the output so let's have a
look at the program as you can see there
are three variables
X Y and Z and we have initialized them 2
4 and 5 respectively
and after that we are calling a function
duplicate
and we are passing the values
but in this case we are passing the
values as reference so this is the case
of call by reference
and we know in case of call by reference
the actual value of the variable also
changes
so here in this question we are passing
the values as reference to this function
named duplicate now inside this function
we can see that every variable each of
these three variables is getting
multiplied by two
so in case of call by value there will
be no change in the actual value but
here we are not passing the arguments as
call by value but we are passing it as
call by reference
so the changes will be reflected in the
actual value
so
when 2 is multiplied by 2 it gives you 4
and 4 is multiplied by 2 is it will give
you 8 and when 5 multiplied by 2 it will
give you 10. so its output would be
4 8 and 10.
now let's move on to the next question
how to write a program to check if the
number is spell in ROM or not
so palindrome is a number That Remains
the Same when its digits are reversed so
here we have to write the program to
check if the number is palindrome or not
so before moving forward there are two
things that you should keep in mind that
if a number is mod by 10 that is number
mod 10 it will give the last digit of
that particular number for example if
there is a number 123
then 123 mode 10 will give you 3.
and if we divide that number by 10 then
that will remove the last digit for
example 123 divided by 10 will give you
12 as an answer
so now let's have a look at this
question inside the int main there are
variables like num digit reverse and n
and after that there is a message saying
enter a positive number after that we
are taking the input num
and we are storing that num variable
inside another variable that is n
we'll talk about this later why we are
storing this to another variable n
now there's a do block inside the do
block we can see digit equals num mode
10. now to understand this let us take
an example as
let us suppose the number to be 123. now
num is that number and we know that
123 mode 10 equals to 3 that means the
last digit of that number so now digit
is storing the last digit of that number
after that we can see reverse equals to
reverse into 10 plus digit now we know
that reverse we have initialized as 0 so
reverse equal to 0 Plus 3.
now reverse now becomes equal to 3.
after that we can see in the next line
num equals to num divided by 10. that
means 123 divided by 10 and as we have
already discussed 123 divided by 10 will
give you 12.
now
now this 12 will again go to num mode 10
and
the value of Digit now will become 2.
now this 2 will be added in the second
line as we can see and reverse is 3 as
we know now 3 into 10 becomes 30 plus
digit which is now 2 that becomes 32.
and after that line num equals to num
divided by 10
will remove that 2 from the 12. so now
the value of num is 1. now again the num
will go to number 10
one more 10 gives you 1. so now the
value of Digit is 1 and in the next line
reverse value is now 32 so 32 into 10
becomes 320 after that we will add the
value of Digit that is equal to 1 so it
will become 320 plus 1 that will give
you 321
so after that the condition of while
loop terminates
and after that we can see the reverse of
the number is Rev reverse because the
result is stored at this variable
now I'll tell you why we have stored num
into the variable n because we don't
want to make changes with the num
variable that is the user input
and here we have used if condition and
inside the if condition all we have
written is if the value that is entered
by the user is equal to the reverse of
that particular value then that number
is a palindrome else the number is not a
palindrome
now coming to the next question
which of the following will give the
size of object or type
so the right answer is the size of
operator gives the size of object or
type
now let's move on to the next question
which of the following is not a member
of class
so the answer is among the following
friend function is not the member of a
class
now let's move on to 31st question
that is what is STL
STL stands for standard template Library
it is a library container that provides
generic classes and functions
STL components are containers algorithms
iterators and function objects
so next question is what is a friend
function
a friend function can be defined as a
function that can access private public
and protected member of the class
the friend function is declared using
the front keyword this function is
declared inside the class
now next is what is a copy Constructor
a copy Constructor is a member function
that initialize an object using another
object within the same class
The Constructor is of two types default
copy Constructor and user defined copy
Constructor
now let's move on to the next question
how does the strings are stored in the
memory
options are sequence null non-contiguous
contiguous
so the correct answer is
the characters of strings are stored
contiguously in the memory
moving to the next question
what is inheritance
inheritance is the mechanism in which we
can create a new class that is child
class from the existing class that is
parent class
this child class is also known as
derived class and the parent class is
also called Base Class
and in The Inheritance child class
inherits properties and behavior from
its parent class
so our next question is
what is abstraction
abstraction can be defined as a
technique in which we only show the
functionality to the user that is the
details that we want the user to see and
hiding the internal details or
implementation details which is not
necessary for a user to see
now let's move on to the next question
what is the output of the below code
so here we can see they have used
ternary operator in this question
so first of all as we can see there are
three variables a b and c and five and
six are the values of A and B that have
been assigned to them
and at line 11 we can see a greater than
b question mark a colon B so this is a
ternary operator
here a greater than b is the test
expression if this test expression is
true then
the expression after the question mark
that is a will be the answer and if it
is false then the expression after colon
that is B will be the answer that means
if a is greater than b then a will be
the answer and if a is not greater than
b then B will be the answer
and as you can see the value of a is 5
and the value of B is 6 so the test
expression is false so that means B will
be the answer
so now the value of C is B that is
6. so our correct answer is 6.
now let's move on to the next question
what among these is used to return the
number of characters in the string
option A is size option b is length C is
both size and length and option D is
name
so the answer is both size and length
will return the number of characters in
The String now let's move to the 39th
question
what is the output of the below code as
we can see in this code the value of J
is 10
then the value of J is incremented as
you can see in the line 10
J plus plus so the value of J is
incremented to 11. after that J is ADD
D200 and at last J is added to 999 which
will give us the result as
1010 that is 10 10. and this value is
being assigned to I
so our answer is
10 10.
now let's move to the next question that
is the last question
pick the correct statement about string
objects in C plus plus
option A is string objects must be
terminated by a null character option b
is string objects have static size
option C is string objects have a
dynamic size option D is string objects
use extra memory then required
so our correct answer is
C string objects have Dynamic size they
are dynamic in nature that is their size
varies as their value changes so they
don't use any extra memory
so these were some important C plus plus
interview questions
now with that we have come to an end of
day three of software development I hope
the session was informative and
interesting on the day 4 of software
development we will learn the dominant
programming language which is Java if
you have any queries related to any of
the topics discussed in the session then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be happy to resolve all
your queries until next time thank you
for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to